Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 158. Jetzt hab ich das Chaosradio langsam eingeholt hier mit der Anzahl der Sendungen. Ja, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove, hallo, ich begrüße euch wie immer und heute geht es um, ja heute geht es um Demokratie im weiteren Sinne, aber auch im ganz besonderen, konkret möchte ich das Konzept von Liquid Democracy ein wenig näher erarbeiten und dabei auch noch einen Blick auf eine damit verbundene Software eröffnen und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gast und Gesprächspartner und auskunftsfreudigen Menschen Jan, Jan Behrens, hallo, ja hallo, willkommen bei Chaosradio Express. Ja, wo fängt man da denn überhaupt an? Also große Worte, Demokratie nicht wahr? Wir wollen ja mal alles besser machen und alle sollen frei sein und alle sollen irgendwie ihr Potenzial zum Guten einbringen. Bloß wie man dann eben konkret davor geht und wie man dann so den Konsens findet in der Gesellschaft, das ist ja so eine strittige Sache.
Ja, das stimmt. Also ganz konkret ist es ja so bei der Demokratie. Eigentlich ist halt immer gewünscht, dass eine möglichst direkte Beteiligung der Menschen, die halt Stimmen eben möglich ist. Und ja, direkte Demokratie hat halt ein Problem. Sie skaliert halt sehr schlecht. Und da setzt sozusagen dann auch Liquid Democracy an.
Skaliert schlecht. Das ist doch ein schöner technischer Begriff. Was meinst du denn damit? Was skaliert denn an Demokratie nicht?
Naja, das Problem ist, dass, wenn die Entscheidungsprozesse halt sehr komplex ist, ist halt sehr schwierig, dass jede Person auch tatsächlich mit jedem Thema in aller Tiefe beschäftigt.
Oder zumindest müsste.
Genau. Also wenn man halt auch gute Entscheidungen am Ende haben möchte, dann ist es halt auch notwendig, dass die Leute, die eben entscheiden, auch tatsächlich wissen, worüber sie entscheiden, was sie entscheiden. Und wenn sie halt irgendwie ja nur danach abstimmen, wie irgendwie der Titel aussieht oder wie die Gesichter aussehen, dann ist es halt ein Problem.
Und das ist sozusagen etwas, wo das Modell Liquid Democracy ansetzt. Bevor wir da gleich komplett eintauchen, vielleicht noch so ein bisschen was zu deiner Person. Was hat dich so, was ist so dein Hintergrund und was hat dich dazu bewogen, dich mit solchen Themen auseinanderzusetzen?
Also ich habe mich im letzten Sommer, also Sommer 2009, bin ich bei der Piratenpartei eingetreten und da habe ich halt mitbekommen, dass die halt an Liquid Democracy arbeiten. Ich habe irgendwie gesehen, dass es nicht so recht vorangeht damit und das war für mich halt der Grund, anzufangen, auch eine konkrete Software zu entwickeln.
Aber ich meine, damit hat dein Leben nicht unbedingt angefangen, dass du so Piratenpartei eingetreten bist?
Ansonsten beschäftige ich mich halt sehr viel mit Programmieren, auch beruflich und ja, das interessiert mich halt schon mein ganzes Leben lang.
Auch die demokratische Teil, ich meine, bist du sozusagen jetzt so politisch schon immer da auch präsent gewesen oder ist das jetzt...
Nein, ich habe eigentlich......durch die Piraten überhaupt erst erweckt worden? Eigentlich erst durch die Piraten erweckt, also ich habe politisch davor eigentlich überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Was hat es dann sozusagen...
Also der Auslöser war ganz klar die Debatte um die Internetsensur. Da habe ich halt gesagt, es geht jetzt gar nicht mehr. Also die Piraten kannte ich halt auch schon vorher. Sie waren mir halt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, halt ein bisschen zu inkonsequent in manchen Forderungen. Aber mit der Zensurdebatte musste ich dann einfach zu dem Schluss kommen, jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt, wo man sich einfach engagieren muss politisch.
Ja, Boamira Bisse hast du gesagt, das heißt, du hast ja auch gleich so diesen Urtsch gespürt, die richtigen Werkzeuge sozusagen zu machen. Also Liquid Democracy ist ja in dem Sinne jetzt auch nichts Neues, und das ist auch nichts, was die Piraten erfunden haben, das muss man auch mal dazu sagen. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, wann dieser Begriff als solcher überhaupt gegründet wurde. Also wo der herkommt.
Ich muss sagen, das weiß ich auch nicht genau. Ich habe halt bei Wikipedia dazu gelesen, irgendwie Jahre 2003 etwa. Also es geht halt zurück eigentlich auf Stimmendelegation, also Delegated Voting oder Proxy Voting, wo man halt eben nicht selber abstimmen, also nicht nur selber abstimmen kann, sondern eben auch eine andere Person, seine eigene Stimme an eine andere Person delegieren kann, die dann für einen abstimmt. Ursprünglich ist das Ganze halt eher als eine Art Vertretungsregelung gewesen, also es ist eine Art Vertretungsregelung gewesen. Bei Liquid Democracy geht es aber halt über eine Vertretung hinaus, sondern die Delegation der Stimme ist sozusagen Teil eines Konzepts, die ist sozusagen kein Notbehelf, ich bin jetzt irgendwie krank und deswegen delegiere ich an eine andere Person, sondern die ist sozusagen gewünscht, um sich bei Themen tatsächlich aufzuteilen, zu spezialisieren und eben dieses Problem der Skalierung der direkten Demokratie zu lösen.
Das ist ja das, was ihr jetzt auch eingangs gesagt hast, das heißt, Demokratie, also alle Macht, geht vom Folge aus. Natürlich so ein Ideal, was ja auch in unserer Gesellschaft so nicht funktioniert, haben wir ja jetzt gerade gestern wieder bei der Bundespräsidentenwahl schön sehen können. Da wurde ja auch sehr viel delegiert an Macht und das eben dann an wenige Leute. Also wir haben ja im Prinzip schon ein Delegationssystem. Man delegiert ja alles in den Bundestag und die machen dann...
Ja, wobei, da ist halt zu Liquid Democracy ein wesentlicher Unterschied. Bei dem Bundestag, wenn ich dort delegiere, dann tue ich das für vier Jahre erst mal. Das heißt, ich kann diese Delegation nicht jederzeit wieder rufen. Das ist bei Liquid Democracy anders. Und der zweite Unterschied ist, dass ich eben auch nicht themenbezogen delegieren kann. Also ein Teil von Liquid Democracy ist auch, dass ich bei bestimmten Themen unterschiedliche Personen delegiere. Das heißt, dass sozusagen die Delegation oder auch Delegierten-Systeme bei Parteien, die haben erst mal nur sehr wenig tatsächlich mit der Delegation bei Liquid Democracy zu tun. Das ist halt schon was anderes.
Okay, das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist die Grundidee einfach die, die Leute, die sich mit diesem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben, haben sich angeschaut, okay, Demokratie, das ist ja eigentlich alles was Tolles. Und man möchte natürlich, dass möglichst viele Leute sich an diesem politischen Willenbildungsprozess beteiligen, denn, so lautet die Lehre und die Einsicht, wenn umso mehr Leute sich daran beteiligen, umso klüger sind dann die Entscheidungen, weil eben mehr Willen berücksichtigt wird. Damit ist dann im Umkehrschluss wahrscheinlich dann auch die Akzeptanz der gefällten Entscheidungen natürlich entsprechend hoch, weil wenn es dann eben eine Mehrheit trägt, dann ist auch die Mehrheit und der Großteil der Gesellschaft irgendwie zufrieden und vielleicht eben auch die Leute, die jetzt so unmittelbar für die gewählte Lösung dann nicht zu haben waren, sehen dann zumindest ein, na ja, aber wenn alle anderen das wollen und so weiter. Und ich meine, da gibt es ja auch verschiedenste Modelle, wie das gemacht wird. Man braucht jetzt hier nur in den Süden zu schauen, in die Schweiz, immer ein beliebtes Beispiel, die ja auch sehr viel von ihrer Demokratie halten, zu Recht, wie ich finde, auch das als ein sehr direktes System verstehen, was dann aber quasi bedeutet, dass man eben dann sich auch mit extrem vielen Dingen beschäftigen muss. Permanent wird man befragt und im Laufe der Meter gibt es irgendwelche Abstimmungen zu jedem Kram. Da soll eine neue Turnhalle gebaut werden, so alle können irgendwie mitreden und haben dann auch so viele Einflussmöglichkeiten, dass sie solche Entscheidungen auch wieder rückgängig machen können, selbst wenn sie von irgendeinem Rat schon gefällt wurden. Ich bin jetzt nicht wirklich gut mit dem demokratischen Modell der Schweiz vertraut, aber das ist ja auch allseits bekannt. Das heißt, hier funktioniert es dadurch, dass man eben eine möglichst breite Beteiligung macht und offensichtlich funktioniert es auch noch soweit so gut, dass eben sich auch sehr viele Leute beteiligen. Wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, ist aber sozusagen die Einzige bei Liquid Democracy, die, naja, das ist irgendwie alles schön und gut, aber funktioniert in der Praxis dann auch nur beschränkt, weil es einfach Themen gibt, die man so gar nicht versteht oder gar nicht verstehen will oder einfach die Zeit nicht dafür hat.
Ja, also das Problem ist halt, wie gesagt, dass es ja in der Politik, da geht es ja nicht nur um die Frage A oder B, sondern die Fragen sind ja wesentlich komplizierter. Genaugenommen sind ja sogar die Antwortmöglichkeiten, müssen ja eigentlich von der Politik auch erst erarbeitet werden. Und bei Liquid Democracy sollen eben auch komplexere Fragen tatsächlich beantwortet werden können. Und es soll halt kein Multiple Choice sein. Und das bedeutet halt auch, dass es halt eben, also Demokratie ist halt auch mehr als ein Multiple-Choice-Test. So, es gibt Option A, B, C, was willst du haben. Sondern das ist halt auch einfach mit sehr viel ja auch Textarbeit verbunden. Und das ist halt keine Sache, die man irgendwie nebenher macht.
Also das meint es jetzt sozusagen die konkrete Ausformulierung eines Gesetzes.
Ja genau. Also das ist ja durchaus, hat ja dann auch juristische Auswirkungen und Interdependenzen und ja.
Was ist also jetzt der konkrete Ansatz bei Liquid Democracy? Was schlägt, was wird sozusagen unter diesem Begriff konkret verstanden? Was für einen Vorschlagskatalog geht damit einher?
Also der wesentliche Punkt bei Liquid Democracy an sich ist, dass die Stimmendelegation Grundsatzprinzip ist, um eben eine Arbeitsteilung zu ermöglichen und eben auch eine Entscheidung letztendlich durch Experten, ohne dass dabei aber die Demokratie eingeschränkt wird. Also es soll nun nicht so sein, dass bestimmte Experten dann die Macht haben und entscheiden können, was sie tun wollen, sondern sie sollen eben sozusagen ausgewählt werden von den Leuten. Ich vertraue dieser Person, die ist in dem Thema XY sehr gut geeignet.
Das heißt, diese Experten sind nicht von irgendjemandem gesetzt, sondern diese Experten ergeben sich quasi.
Genau.
Es ist halt, wen auch immer man als Experten ansieht.
Das Ganze ist halt dynamisch. Ich hatte ja auch vorhin erzählt, es ist ein Unterschied zur repräsentativen Demokratie, wo man halt alle vier Jahre wählt. Es ist tatsächlich komplett dynamisch. Ich kann von der einen auf die andere Sekunde sagen, Expertennummer A gefällt mir nicht mehr, jetzt delegiere ich an Expertennummer B. Und ich kann auch vor allem sagen, beide Experten taugen nichts, ich weiß es besser.
An welcher Situation wendet sich das jetzt? Ich meine, an welcher Stelle, um jetzt mal auch ein praktisches Beispiel reinzuziehen, wo könnte das greifen? Also bei der Piratenpartei wird es eingesetzt, wofür vor allem?
Also bei der Piratenpartei ist der Einsatzzweck jetzt momentan in Berlin und auch auf der Bundesebene. Da wird es eingesetzt, um die Mitgliederversammlung vorzubereiten. Das heißt, im Prinzip wird das, was man normalerweise auf einer Mitgliederversammlung entscheidet, einfach vorher in einem Liquid Democracy-System, also konkret jetzt der eingesetzten Software Liquid Feedback, voren entschieden. Und mit diesen Entscheidungen, die dort getroffen sind, geht man dann sozusagen in die Mitgliederversammlung, damit man nicht dort mit tausend Leuten beispielsweise erst mal diskutieren muss, in welche Richtung man möchte, sondern damit man schon weiß eigentlich, wie sieht es aus. Und im Idealfall sozusagen auf der Mitgliederversammlung das Ganze nur noch abnicken muss. Das wird natürlich wahrscheinlich so nicht immer funktionieren, aber es ist halt sozusagen das Ziel eben.
Aber es ist ja auch jetzt schon so, dass bei Mitgliederversammlungen vorher Anträge formuliert werden und dann im Wesentlichen nur noch zur Abstimmung gestellt werden.
Ja, wobei der Unterschied natürlich ist, dass bei Liquid Democracy natürlich die Leute mit ihrem Stimmgewicht berücksichtigt werden, dass man schon vorher tatsächlich auch quantifiziert, welche Anträge oder welche Änderungen von Anträgen sind sozusagen gewünscht oder nicht gewünscht. Also im Prinzip wird der ganze Entscheidungsprozess schon mal vorweggenommen. Und ja, im Prinzip könnte man sich, wenn es da keine Vorgaben vom Parteiengesetz und auch bestimmte Vorbehalte, auch bestimmte Vorbehalte, die es ja zurecht gibt, geben würde, könnte man sich quasi die Mitgliederversammlung auch sparen. Also rein von dem, was die Software eigentlich leisten kann.
Ist denn Liquid Democracy etwas, was man nur mit Software machen kann?
Da muss ich sagen, habe ich noch gar nicht so drüber nachgedacht. Ich denke zumindest, wenn man das Ganze so dynamisch und so in Echtzeit haben möchte, dann muss das schon mit Software gemacht werden. Was auf jeden Fall wichtig ist, meiner Meinung nach zumindest, ist, dass die Prozesse alle dokumentiert werden. Und das ist natürlich, wenn man das mit Papier machen will, ist es natürlich ein erheblicher Aufwand.
Also die Prozesse im Wesentlichen sozusagen das Vergeben von Delegationen. Du hast ja gesagt, ich kann diese Delegation thematisch vergeben. Wodurch ergibt sich sozusagen dieses Themenfeld? Wo fängt das an?
Ja, das ist das.
Und wo endet das?
Das ist natürlich eine sehr gute Frage. Konkret ist es so, dass man sich halt darauf einigen muss. Also wenn man zum Beispiel als Organisation Liquid Democracy einsetzt, dann muss man sich halt entscheiden, was für Themenbereiche gibt es eigentlich? Und wie grenzen wir die voneinander ab? Das ist natürlich eine auch subjektive Frage. Also die Frage ist, ja, was passt denn nun in Bereich X und ist nicht vielleicht irgendein Thema, viel eher Thema Y? Und das Einzige, was man da halt tun kann, ist tatsächlich versuchen, möglichst klare Regelungen aufzustellen, wie weit sozusagen die Entscheidungsbefugnis von Entscheidungen in einem dieser Themenbereiche dann tatsächlich ist. Und wenn halt ein Themenbereich etwas beschließt, was über seine Kompetenzen hinausgeht, muss man das halt für ungültig erachten. Also ganz konkret, wenn halt im Bereich Agrar sozusagen Software-Patente beschlossen werden, dann gilt es halt einfach nicht.
Das heißt, das ist eigentlich, an der Stelle ist es eigentlich noch total fuzzy. Und an der Stelle ist sozusagen eigentlich überhaupt erstmal die eigentliche Organisation oder Gemeinschaft gefordert, sich quasi selbst erstmal ein Regelwerk zu erstellen, was eben diese Themen abgrenzt. Aber man muss es ja auch nicht machen. Man könnte ja auch sagen, wir sind so monothematisch, dass wir unsere Inhalte überhaupt gar nicht auf mehrere Themen verteilen können. Wir haben halt nur das eine. Was weiß ich, Kegelclub alle Neune. Es gibt irgendwie ausschließlich Dinge, die diesen Kegelclub betreffen und vielleicht die Bahnen, wann man sich trifft und so weiter und wann man irgendwie die nächste Sitzung abhält und wie viel Biere zwischen zwei Kegelwürfen geworfen werden dürfen. Da ist es jetzt vielleicht nicht so wichtig, das zu unterscheiden, aber wenn man jetzt mal so den Katalog Partei aufmacht, dann ist ja klar, einerseits man will eben diese ganzen Themenfelder, die in der öffentlichen Diskussion sind, besetzen, das ist ja schon genannt, so Agrar hier, Rechtswissenschaften da, das ist irgendwie alles ganz andere Abteilungen, plus eben dann noch den ganzen internen Klimmbimm, der dann definitiv auch so erstmal mit einer öffentlichen Politikformulierung so nichts zu tun hat. Das heißt, wenn man quasi, also wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, Liquid Democracy ist ein Konzept, das sich an Organisationen wendet, die nicht zwingend sich jetzt Partei nennen müssen, sondern das kann im Prinzip jegliche Form von Organisationen sein, wo Leute gemeinsam zusammenkommen und irgendwelche Willensbildung betreiben wollen und die in irgendeiner Form auch eine definierte Gruppengröße haben.
Nicht unbedingt. Man kann sich auch Liquid Democracy durchaus als Staatsform vorstellen. Da gibt es natürlich diverse Probleme.
Na gut, aber ein Staat hat ja auch eine definierte Gruppengröße. Ich meine, da gibt es eine klare Mitgliedschaft.
Wenn du ein Staat als Organisation bezeichnen würdest, ja.
Aber ich kann ja jetzt, sagen wir mal, jetzt bei Piraten nicht Mitwillensbildung betreiben innerhalb ihres Liquid Democracy-Systems, ohne selber ein Mitglied zu sein.
Ja, genau. Wobei die Frage ist natürlich, was da gewünscht ist. Also die Piratenpartei kann natürlich ein solches Werkzeug einsetzen, um entweder innerparteilich Entscheidungen zu treffen. Da ist natürlich dann die Mitgliedschaft Voraussetzung für eine solche Teilnahme. Man könnte aber natürlich auch sagen, ja, wir möchten so etwas ermöglichen, wo jeder Bürger sich beteiligen kann. Das ist natürlich ein ganz anderer Anwendungsfall. Und es ist auch wichtig, das zu unterscheiden.
Da werden wir sicherlich auch noch ein bisschen hinkommen, das einzuschätzen, inwieweit jetzt so eine geschlossene Gruppe und so eine klar definierte Mitgliedschaft da von Vorteil ist oder sogar notwendig oder nicht. Aber Liquid Democracy ist also quasi jetzt für Gruppen, wie groß sie jetzt auch immer sein mögen. Und wenn man dann dieses Konzept auch einsetzen will, dann bedeutet das eigentlich, ich habe eine Stimme. Und in dem Moment, wo wir mehrere Themen aufspannen und sagen, es gibt hier mehr oder weniger klar abgegrenzte Bereiche, die in den meisten Fällen vielleicht klar abgegrenzt sind und manchen muss man vielleicht auch nochmal drüber reden, ob es in das eine oder in das andere besser reinpasst. Und je nachdem, in welchem dieser Themenfelder man jetzt gerade aktiv wird oder eben auch nicht. Bestimmt man, ob man seine Stimme selbst wahrnimmt oder ob man sie jemand anderen wahrnehmen lässt.
Wobei dazu muss man halt noch sagen, also zumindest bei unserer konkreten Umsetzung, die wir jetzt programmiert haben, ist es so, dass man auch ganz konkret auf bestimmte Abstimmungen das selber entscheiden kann. Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, im Themenbereich Außenpolitik delegiere ich normalerweise, aber wenn halt irgendeine bestimmte Abstimmung zu einem ganz konkreten Thema da ist, kann ich jederzeit sagen, da stimme ich jetzt doch selber ab.
Okay, also es ist sozusagen keine Einstellung für das ganze Themenfeld, sondern es ist sozusagen, ich kann hier delegieren, genau, dann delegiere ich aber immer nur an eine Person für das gesamte Themenfeld.
Ja, genau. Ich kann sogar für bestimmte Abstimmungen auch nochmal dort eine andere delegiert sein.
Okay, das heißt, in dem Moment, wo es einen konkreten Fall gibt, dann kann ich für diesen konkreten Fall bestimmen, ob hier sozusagen meine Default-Delegation zum Tragen kommt. Keine Delegation zum Tragen kommt, ich einfach sage, ich kenne mich zwar in diesem Bereich nicht besonders gut aus, aber hier habe ich eine klare Meinung. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer, beziehungsweise hier habe ich zwar auch keine klare Meinung, aber da kenne ich jemanden, der da noch sehr viel konkret kompetenter ist für diesen Bereich, meiner Auffassung nach, als derjenige, dem ich das normalerweise überlassen würde.
Ja, genau. Der Clou hierbei ist aber noch, dass Delegationen transitiv sind, das heißt, sie sind weiter übertragbar. Und das ist auch ganz wichtig, weil ich somit nicht nur jemandem delegieren kann, von dem ich weiß, dass er sich mit dem Sachthema gut auskennt, sondern ich kann auch an jemanden delegieren, von dem ich weiß, dass er wahrscheinlich besser weiß, wer sich damit auskennt.
Der sozusagen die Personalstruktur besser einschätzen kann der Organisation.
Also wenn ich zum Beispiel, ich bin zum Beispiel angenommen, ich bin Pirat, ich kenne mich irgendwie relativ schlecht aus, wer in der Piratenpartei was gut kann, dann kann ich halt an jemanden delegieren, der halt vielleicht mehr involviert ist und dem ich aber auch zutraue, an die Personen zu delegieren, die dann in meinem Sinne entscheiden werden.
So, dein Freund, der dich überhaupt erst mal in das Projekt mit reingebracht hat?
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Dem du auch ein gewisses Vertrauen entgegenbringst und weißt, wie er so tickt. Und dann kann es sein, dass, obwohl du ihm was delegierst, in 80 Prozent der Fälle diese Delegation wiederum bei einer anderen Person landest. Das heißt, es entsteht sozusagen so eine Kaskade von Delegationen.
Ja, genau. Also ein Baum. Es gibt da noch den Fall, dass es auch Zyklen geben kann. Also es ist eigentlich ein Graf, es ist kein Baum, aber es ist eine Detailfrage.
Also eine Zykle meinst du, dass man dann wieder über fünf Ecken rumdelegiere und derjenige beschließt, das mir zu delegieren?
Ja, genau. Also das kann passieren, dass sich eben Kreise bilden. In der Praxis ist das allerdings kein Problem, denn ich hatte ja gesagt, man kann sich jederzeit selber beteiligen. Wenn ein Kreis überhaupt Relevanz haben soll, dann muss sich ja einer in diesem Kreis beteiligen. Und in diesem Fall gilt ja die ausgehende Delegation nicht mehr. Das heißt, Kreise werden sozusagen automatisch aufgelöst.
Was heißt das? Das heißt, dass in dem Moment, wo jemand was an mich zurückdelegiert, dass ich dann doch selber wieder abstimmen muss?
Nee, das heißt nicht, dass du selber wieder abstimmen musst, sondern dass wenn einer in diesem Kreis abstimmt, alle anderen automatisch dann mit ihrer Stimme sich da dranhängen.
Äh, also wenn wir jetzt irgendwie drei Leute sind und A delegiert an B und B an C und C an A?
Genau. Dann wird erstmal, wenn keiner von A bis C abstimmt, dann passiert erstmal nichts. So. Und wenn jetzt aber...
Weil sie sozusagen die gesamte Gruppe einfach komplett erstmal überhaupt gar nicht mit diesem Thema befasst. Das ist ja auch bei Delegated Voting ist es sozusagen möglich, komplett alles zu ignorieren.
Ja, das ist vielleicht...
Nicht, dass es so einen Abstimmungszwang gibt, oder?
Nee, nee. Also es ist vielleicht auch, ja auch nochmal ganz wichtig zu sagen, Liquid Democracy löst natürlich nicht das Problem, dass es tatsächlich auch Leute geben muss, die die Arbeit tun.
Das kommt jetzt sehr überraschend.
Ja, aber man muss halt sehen, dass es halt auch nur das leisten kann, was tatsächlich die Leute auch reingeben in ein solches System. Das muss man sich halt immer wieder vor Augen führen auch tatsächlich. Ja, aber nochmal zu den Kreisdelegationen. Also wenn jetzt...
Also wenn keiner was macht, dann gibt es auch gar nichts zu delegieren sozusagen. Klar, aber wenn jetzt irgendeiner von denen sagt...
So wenn jetzt C zum Beispiel anfängt abzustimmen, dann wird B genau das Gleiche tun, weil ja B an C delegiert und A tut auch das Gleiche dann A und C.
Aber er muss dann sozusagen explizit ja dann diese Delegationskette dadurch wieder brechen, weil er sagt, in diesem Fall stimme ich ab, obwohl ich normalerweise... also in dem Moment ist der Kreis sozusagen weg.
Genau.
Das heißt der Kreis existiert eigentlich nur virtuell, solange bis überhaupt keiner irgendwas getan hat.
Genau, also für den Fall, dass C abstimmt, gilt ja die Delegation von C an A nicht mehr, weil die C ja selbst vom Stimmrecht gebraucht machen. Das heißt, diese Kreise sind in der Praxis kein Problem. Sie können halt eben auftreten, solange wie sich jemand anfängt zu beteiligen. In dem Fall löst sich der Kreis automatisch auf.
Das heißt, es gibt eigentlich gar keine Kreise.
Ja, genau.
Es ist einfach nur so, es dreht sich alles im Kreis, solange bis irgendjemand da konkret ausschlägt und dann...
Wobei in der Praxis, in der Praxis entstehen, ich habe es jetzt nicht genau verfolgt, aber ich meine, dass da meistens halt so ein Hin- oder Herdelegieren, also A delegiert an B, B an A, dass da drei Leute involviert sind, das ist schon... Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob bei den Piraten es überhaupt schon aufgetreten ist, aber es ist halt einfach möglich und die Software muss halt damit umgehen können und nicht in einer Endlustschleife versacken.
So, jetzt stelle ich mir das halt nochmal so vor. Ich habe jetzt hier irgendwie meinen Kegelklub und Dinge sollen beschlossen werden. Da muss es ja jetzt erstmal in irgendeiner Form, jetzt überlege ich gerade mal, wenn wir jetzt konkret werden, reden wir ja eigentlich schon dann auch so über diese Software. Bevor wir vielleicht das tun, was jetzt sozusagen diesen Überbau betrifft, sozusagen Liquid Democracy als Idee, bist du eigentlich auch in diesem Verein? Es gibt ja einen speziellen Verein, der sich gegründet hat, um Liquid Democracy voranzubringen...
Liquid Democracy V bin ich nicht.
Okay, aber sowas gibt es, wo Leute sich zusammengefunden haben, sozusagen um die Idee als solche unabhängig von jetzt einer konkreten Software und Implementierung zu unterstützen. Ist denn diese Geschichte mit der Delegation im Prinzip schon alles? Ist das sozusagen alles, was unter dem Begriff Liquid Democracy zusammengefasst ist?
Ja, da muss man halt ein bisschen aufpassen. Liquid Democracy, verschiedene Leute verstehen verschiedene Sachen darunter. Also meine Auffassung wäre halt, dass Liquid Democracy eben ein dynamisches Delegated Voting mit transitiven Delegationen ist. Das verstehe ich unter Liquid Democracy. Andere Leute verstehen vielleicht was anderes darunter. Konkret, die Software Liquid Feedback macht auch mehr als Delegated Voting, aber das würde ich halt nicht als Liquid Democracy bezeichnen.
Okay, das heißt, diese Software implementiert Dinge, die Liquid Democracy quasi als Konzept formuliert hat.
Genau.
Es macht aber auch noch andere Sachen.
Und gibt es irgendwelche Konzepte in Liquid Democracy, die jetzt noch dazukommen, zusätzlich zu diesem Delegated Voting? Also eigentlich nicht.
Also nach meiner Definition ist halt eben...
Aber du meinest ja, andere Leute sehen es anders. Fällt dir da jetzt was Konkretes ein? Inwieweit die das anders sehen, was die der Meinung sind, was jetzt noch dazugehört?
Also genau kann ich das nicht sagen, aber das war alles eher etwas diffus.
Okay, na gut, dann bleiben wir einfach mal bei dieser Definition. Das heißt, um es nochmal abzuschließen, die Kernidee ist einfach die, man will demokratische Beteiligung fördern. Man will sozusagen, wenn ich es richtig verstehe, auch mehr Ermutigung aussprechen sozusagen zur Beteiligung.
Ja, es ist nicht nur Ermutigung zur Beteiligung. Eigentlich geht es darum, dass tatsächlich jede Person berücksichtigt wird. Und zwar unabhängig davon, wie viel Zeit sie investiert. Das bedeutet, dass ich eben auch genauso viel Berücksichtigung mit meinem Stimmgewicht finde, wenn ich mir keinen dieser Anträge, die in dem System sind, durchlese. Ich habe also die gleiche, ich werde genauso berücksichtigt, wenn ich einfach nur sage, ich delegiere an meinen Vertreter, der nimmt meine Interessen wahr und ansonsten habe ich mit dem System nichts zu tun. Das heißt, es geht hier nicht nur um aktive Beteiligung, sondern es geht auch darum, die Menschen zu berücksichtigen, die stimmberechtigt sind. Unabhängig davon, wie viel Zeit sie haben.
Aber ist das nicht auch so ein Jubelperzer-Generator? Ich tritt da mal so in die Partei an und dann hole ich noch so meine 50 Freunde mit. Die müssen eigentlich gar nichts anderes tun, als da sich einmal reinzuwählen und zu sagen, ja hier, der Zilv, der macht schon alles richtig und so. Und dann gehen die wieder nach Hause und bohren in der Nase. Und ich habe dann sozusagen die Power of 50 und bin dann erstmal der Zampano.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein berechtigter Einwand. Und dazu muss man halt einfach sagen, die Beteiligungsschwelle wird halt gesenkt. Im Prinzip könntest du ja das Gleiche auch machen, auch wenn es einen Parteitag gibt. Der Unterschied ist halt natürlich, dass deine 50 Leute dann auf dem Parteitag erscheinen müssen, wenn sie tatsächlich in deinem Sinne abstimmen sollen. Mit der Technik und mit einer Delegation wird das Ganze natürlich einfacher. Es werden also Schwellen gesenkt. Das kann natürlich auch Nebenwirkungen haben und das muss man sich auch bewusst machen. Und es ist halt letztendlich die Frage, meiner Meinung nach sollte man halt keine Hürden aufstellen, also keine künstlichen Hürden aufstellen, sondern wenn man als Partei eben entscheiden möchte, dann muss man sich halt überlegen, wie man als Mitglied aufnimmt, meiner Meinung nach. Wenn man halt jeden aufnimmt, muss man halt damit leben. Das ist dann halt die Konsequenz.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die Situation der FDP vor 10, 15 Jahren in Berlin, als die Studenten mal beschlossen haben, wir übernehmen jetzt mal den Club. Die haben ja eh fast keine Mitglieder. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wie erfolgreich sie waren. Letzten Endes hat es nicht nennenswert zu einer Änderung der Politik der FDP beigetragen, soweit ich das sehen kann, aber da haben die ja auch ganz schön geschlattert. Das ist natürlich ein Problem, was man eigentlich in jedem Verein hat, auch unabhängig von solcher Delegationsgeschichte.
Der entscheidende Punkt ist halt eben, die Hürden werden geringer. Das ist halt eigentlich ein positiver Effekt, es kann aber eben auch ausgenutzt werden.
Aber es ist ja auch so, dass diese Delegation keine geheime Geschichte ist, sondern in dem Moment, wo sich jetzt so eine Delegationskonstellation, 50 Leute unterstützen alle eine Person und die sind alle gerade frisch eingetreten, das ist ja eine öffentliche Sache. Wir reden ja hier nicht über geheime Wahlen in dem Sinne.
Nein, also das ist auch ganz wichtig zu sehen. Also meiner Meinung nach kann Liquid Democracy nur funktionieren, wenn man halt in irgendeiner Form namentliche Abstimmungen hat. Das heißt, dass tatsächlich die Prozesse, die passieren, offengelegt werden, konkret im Falle der Piratenpartei. Die Piraten haben sich entschieden, namentlich im Sinne von mit Pseudonym zu interpretieren. Das kann man auch tun.
Das heißt, es ist nachvollziehbar, dass es eine Person gibt, die ist in jedem Kontext wiedererkennbar, aber sie ist nicht anonym in dem Sinne, dass man überhaupt gar nicht zuordnen könnte, was wer getan hat.
Im Prinzip gibt es zwei Aspekte, die das von einer anonymen oder geheimen Abstimmung unterscheiden. Der erste Aspekt ist, dass die Personen eine Identität sind, die man auch wiedererkennen kann. Wenn du dich anmeldest im System, bekommst du eine Benutzernummer und Namen. Auch wenn du deinen Namen änderst, wird die Historie aufgezeichnet. Das ist also eine Identität in dem Sinne. Der zweite Aspekt ist, dass bei einer geheimen Abstimmung oder bei einer geheimen Wahl die Forderung ist, dass tatsächlich niemand dein Abstimmungsverhalten oder dein Wahlverhalten einsehen kann. Das ist bei Liquid Democracy anders, alleine schon, weil es irgendein Administrator mit Ruhrechten gibt.
Also es ist sozusagen überhaupt nicht zu verbergen. Von daher kann so ein System gar nicht die Anforderungen an eine geheime Wahl erfüllen. Wir reden hier wirklich um ein öffentliches Tool. Diese ganzen Delegationsstrukturen sind dann in der Regel auch als solche einsehbar.
Ja, das ist richtig. Das ist ja allein schon deshalb notwendig, damit man nachvollziehen kann, warum hat diese Person 50 Stimmen und warum nicht 37 oder 42?
Und dann, was macht man denn dann so als Kegelklub, wenn dann irgendwie der 50-Stimmen-Mann auf einmal im Raum ist?
Das ist halt im Prinzip ein Problem, was ja den Rahmen von Liquid Democracy oder dem eingesetzten Tool eben übersteigt. Du hast ja schon gesagt, das ist halt ein grundsätzliches Problem von Organisationen, dass sie halt auch unterwandert werden können. Also da kann halt eine Software das Problem nicht lösen.
Aber das ist ja sozusagen die Hinterzimmerproblematik. Und an der Stelle ist das Hinterzimmer aber halt sozusagen offene Türen.
Genau.
Weil man sieht ja diese Struktur.
Man sieht genau, was passiert. Und wenn man halt mit echten Namen arbeitet im System, sieht man halt noch besser, was passiert. Mit Pseudonymen ist es halt eingeschränkt. Aber man bekommt halt alles mit, was im System passiert.
Aber das heißt ja, dass man über diese Delegation auch diese ganzen Gruppen, die sich so zusammenfinden und Ähnliches entscheiden und sich gegenseitig unterstützen, dass man das ja dann als solches auch sehen kann.
Ja, genau. Siehst du das als Qualität? Das sehe ich als Qualität auch tatsächlich, weil diese Strukturen eben... Es kommt natürlich darauf an, wo man das einsetzt. Wenn man jetzt das Ganze auf Bevölkerungsebene einsetzt, dann muss man die Frage nochmal ganz anders bewerten, als wenn man das innerhalb einer Partei einsetzt. Also innerhalb einer Partei würde ich das zumindest so bewerten, dass da Transparenz und Nachvollziehbarkeit, wie und durch wen es zu irgendwelchen Entscheidungen kommt, dass das tatsächlich offen gedeckt werden sollte. Es hat natürlich eben den Nebeneffekt, wobei das man eine geheime Abstimmung verhindern kann, dass man auch beeinflusst oder unter Druck gesetzt werden kann. Aber die einzige Möglichkeit, das wirklich sicher auszuschließen, ist die geheime Abstimmung, wie mit Computern nicht geht.
Und letztendlich ist ja die Abstimmung dann nochmal was ganz anderes als diese Antragsformulierung. Also wir reden ja bisher eigentlich immer davon, dass das Werkzeug eigentlich dafür eingesetzt wird, um überhaupt erstmal zu formulieren, worüber man abstimmen will.
Also im Fall von Liquid Feedback ist das tatsächlich so. Es ist halt mehr als so eine Abstimmung. Wenn man jetzt nochmal auf den Griff Liquid Democracy zurückkommt, da würde ich das als gar nicht definiert sehen, worum es nun genau geht. Es ist halt mehr die Sache, dass Stimmen delegiert werden. Bei Liquid Feedback konkret steht halt der Abstimmung eben eine Antrags-Erarbeitungsphase voraus.
Jetzt reden wir mal ein bisschen konkreter. Du hast ja schon erzählt, du kamst in diesen ganzen Piraten-Kontexten und da wurde über Liquid Democracy viel geredet. Aber es gab lange Zeit keine oder nur wenig Implementierungen. Also Liquid Feedback, worüber wir jetzt auch nochmal genauer reden wollen, ist ja nicht das einzige System, was sich bemüht, dieses Liquid Democracy-Modell zu implementieren. Wie sieht es denn da aus in der Softwarelandschaft?
Also wenn man jetzt mal von Liquid Democracy tatsächlich als Delegation an Personen, die einen dann vertreten bzw. Experten, die besser entscheiden können, als man selbst redet, dann ist eigentlich Adhocracy die einzige Software, die mir neben Liquid Feedback einfällt, die ein ähnliches Konzept umsetzt. Adhocracy setzt halt auch dieses Delegated Voting um und es ermöglicht, kollaborativ an Texten zu arbeiten, die dann abgestimmt werden können. Es gibt halt ein paar wesentliche Unterschiede zwischen den beiden Softwaren. Einer der wesentlichen Unterschiede ist meiner Meinung nach, dass LiquidFeedback nicht so sehr auf Kollaboration aller Teilnehmer setzt, sondern dass bei LiquidFeedback davon ausgegangen wird, dass die Leute sich teilweise auch einfach nicht grün sind und nicht kooperieren wollen. Meiner Meinung nach ist es gerade, also auch meiner Erfahrung nach, bei den Piraten ist es halt notwendig, auch tatsächlich nicht anzunehmen, dass eben alle Leute miteinander arbeiten, sondern manchmal ist es halt auch ein Gegeneinander. Das muss man halt leider so sehen. Das harte Ellenbogen-Geschäft des politischen Prozesses. Natürlich ist es halt nicht schön, wenn es so ist. Und es ist natürlich schöner, wenn man irgendwie auch einen Konsens findet. Aber eine Software muss halt eben auch, meiner Meinung nach, damit umgehen können, wenn sich Leute gar nicht einigen. Das darf halt nicht in einem Edit war, wie zum Beispiel in einem Wiki enden. Also in einem Wiki schreibt dann der eine das eine rein, der andere das andere rein und letztendlich resolft dann ein Administrator, was halt auch nicht demokratisch ist.
Was macht dann jetzt Adhocracy nicht? Oder was macht Liquid Feedback zusätzlich, dass da sich so ein Unterschied auftritt?
Also bei Liquid Feedback ist es so, dass das Antragsentwicklungsmodell so aussieht, dass wenn ich einen Antrag einstelle, kann ich selber entscheiden, wer daran editieren darf. Das klingt natürlich jetzt erstmal extrem undemokratisch. Also wenn ich halt irgendeinen Antrag einbaue und jemand anders kann mir halt da nicht reinreden. Erstmal grundsätzlich. Damit das Ganze wiederum demokratisch wird, gibt es halt zwei Konzepte. Und zwar a, ist es jedem möglich, jederzeit eine Alternative neben den Antrag zu stellen. Und das nächste Konzept ist halt, dass das Abstimmungsverfahren eben ein besonders faires Verfahren ist, wenn es sogenannte Klone gibt. Also ähnliche Anträge.
Da kommen wir jetzt schon ein bisschen mit dem fünften Teil an. Also vielleicht lassen wir erst mal Autocracy und andere Implementierungen erstmal beiseite. Ist ein bisschen schwierig, etwas zu vergleichen, was man sich so noch gar nicht vergegenwärtigt hat. Bleiben wir jetzt einfach mal konkret bei Liquid Feedback. Liquid Feedback nimmt für sich in Anspruch, wie du schon gesagt hast, eine Implementierung von Liquid Democracy, aber nicht nur davon zu sein. Und das ist generell ein Werkzeug zum Erarbeiten von Anträgen. Kann man das so sagen? Oder kraft es zu kurz?
Von Beschlüssen eigentlich, würde ich sagen. Es ist dazu da, tatsächlich Beschlüsse zu fassen.
Okay, gut. Also man will irgendwelche Beschlüsse fassen. Und dazu gibt es dieses Werkzeug. So, das ist jetzt erstmal ein System, was irgendwie Benutzer kennen. Und ich kriege dann so einen Account. Wenn ich irgendwie Mitglied bin in meiner Organisation, in meinem Kekliglub, dann habe ich da irgendwie so meinen Account.
Genau.
Der wird mir dann irgendwann zugeteilt. Und hier ist ein Passwort. Und jetzt leg mal los. Und dann logge ich mich auf so einer Webseite ein. Und dann? Was passiert dann? Was finde ich vor in dieser Beschlussfassungswelt?
Also erstmal findest du halt die von der Organisation oder auch von den Mitgliedern beschlossenen Themenbereiche vor. Und in diesen Themenbereichen gibt es halt Anträge, die in verschiedenen Stadien sind. Also die halt entweder noch in der Entwicklung sind oder auch tatsächlich in der Abstimmung. Und dann kannst du halt zum Beispiel klicken auf Sozialpolitik. Und dann siehst du halt, es gibt da die und die Vorschläge, die und die sind noch in Diskussion, die und die sind in Abstimmung. Und ja, die einfachste Form der Beteiligung ist halt einfach abzustimmen oder bei Anträgen, die halt noch in der Entwicklung sind, zu sagen, unterstütze ich oder Anregungen dazu zu geben. Oder eben, dass du einfach im System dir anguckst, was für andere Personen gibt es da, die vielleicht deine Freunde raussuchst oder Leute, von denen du meinst, dass sie halt dich sehr gut vertreten oder dass sie sich sehr gut auskennen in einem Thema und vergibst dann Delegationen in jedem Themenbereich oder auch für alle Themenbereiche.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt selber dort etwas zur Beschlussfassung bringen möchte, wenn ich also jetzt mal selber sage, ok, alles klar, ich habe irgendwie total tolle Vorstellungen davon, wie dieser Planet sich weiterentwickeln soll, dann, was mache ich dann? Dann habe ich irgendwo einen Button und sage, hier, neuer Antrag.
Also erstmal, was du natürlich erstmal tun kannst, ist gucken, gibt es überhaupt schon vielleicht einen Antrag, der deinem Antrag nahe kommt.
Ahja, wie finde ich den?
Den kannst du entweder durch eine Textsuche oder halt, indem du anguckst, was es für Anträge gibt. Die sind halt so sortiert, dass halt die Beliebtesten erstmal oben kommen und alles, was halt, ja, was halt nicht beliebt ist, landet halt unten eben. Das ist halt nötig, damit man eben nicht untergeht in einer Flut, wenn man durch das System durchguckt.
Ja, wodurch macht sich diese Beliebtheit fest?
Die Beliebtheit macht sich eben fest an Unterstützerstimmen. Das heißt, in der Antragsentwicklungsphase kann ich Anträge unterstützen. Und je mehr Unterstützung sie bekommen, umso weiter wandern sie halt eben auch nach oben. Wobei auch hier eben das Prinzip des Delegated Voting umgesetzt ist. Das bedeutet, wenn du halt eben sehr viele Delegationen hast von anderen Personen, die sich selber in einem Thema nicht beteiligen, und du sagst, diesen Antrag unterstütze ich, dann hast du halt eben auch entsprechend höheres Stimmgewicht.
Das heißt, so ein Antrag durchläuft verschiedene Phasen, sagst du?
Genau.
Und was sind das jetzt für Phasen? Also irgendjemand hat jetzt so einen Antrag in die Welt gesetzt. Oder bleiben wir vielleicht mal bei dem Beispiel, ich mache das so. Ich mache jetzt irgendwie so einen Antrag. Dann muss ich da was reinschreiben. Dann muss das Ding einen Titel haben und wahrscheinlich einen Absatz, wo drauf steht, worum es geht.
Genau. In der Regel musst du dann auch noch auswählen, um was für ein Verfahren es gibt. Also bei LiquidFeedback kann man verschiedene Verfahrensparameter festlegen, die halt Auswirkungen darauf haben, wie lange diese Antragsphasen sind, was für Quoren erreicht werden müssen, ob vielleicht eine Zweidrittelmehrheit erforderlich ist für die Art von Thema, die du abstimmst. Also wenn du zum Beispiel eine Satzungsänderung anstrebst, würdest du halt auswählen, Satzungsänderung. Und in dem Fall würde halt auch ein Zweidrittelquorum benötigt werden.
Also okay, lass uns mal da einzeln durchgehen. Also ich hab jetzt irgendwie den Antrag und ich hab den Titel und ich hab eine Beschreibung. Was muss ich als nächstes festlegen? Ein Quorum?
Also um was für ein Verfahren es sich handelt. Ob das halt ein Meinungsbild ist oder ob das halt ein Satzungsänderungsantrag ist oder...
Das sind auch sozusagen Typen, das ist sozusagen organisationsspezifisch.
Genau. Genau wie die Themenbereich.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man so ein System überhaupt erstmal aufsetzt, muss man nicht nur festlegen, was für Themenfelder es gibt und welche Benutzer, sondern man muss auch sagen...
Was für Verfahrensarten.
Okay, dann sag mal ein paar Beispiele was.
Also ein Beispiel ist zum Beispiel bei der Piratenpartei Meinungsbild, Beschlussvorlage für den Vorstand, Grundsatzprogrammänderung, Satzungsänderung, Eilverfahren.
Auf was sich das sozusagen bezieht. Das heißt, ein Meinungsbild ist auch etwas, ich schlage jetzt hier mal was vor, ihr könnt das irgendwie unterstützen und ihr könnt dafür stimmen, aber wenn das dann sozusagen angenommen wird und sich in großer Beteiligung erfreut, sagt das erstmal gar nichts aus, weil das ist ja nur ein Meinungsbild.
Ja, also konkret heißt das Verfahren bei den Piraten Meinungsbild-Beschlussvorlage, also das geht ineinander über. Es dient halt sozusagen dazu, dem Vorstand zu sagen, was will die Basis eigentlich, damit der Vorstand eben...
Aber das wäre ja auch erstmal so ein niedrigschwelliger Diskussionsansatz, dass man erstmal so einen Testballon startet und sagt, was wäre wenn.
Wie gesagt, wie verbindlich das ist, entscheidet halt die Organisation.
Die Software verbindet jetzt mit diesem Verfahrenstyp eigentlich kein besonderes Verhalten. Das Verhalten, wie man mit diesen Anträgen umgeht, ist immer dasselbe. Es ist sozusagen nur so eine Eigenschaft, die man festlegt. Man sagt, das ist jetzt ein Meinungsbild, und dann weiß man, was damit gemeint ist.
Es geht noch darüber hinaus, weil es wie gesagt eben auch die Fristen, auf die Fristen und auf die Quoren eben...
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen eine Eigenschaft dieses Verfahrenstypen. Wenn ich sage Meinungsbild, dann heißt das, das läuft dann, was weiß ich, ein paar Wochen.
Ja genau, zum Beispiel.
Und wenn ich sage, das ist eine Satzungsänderung, das ist schwerwiegend, da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie ein halbes Jahr darüber diskutieren.
Das heißt, das ist dann eben das, was man beim Einrichten des Systems mit festlegen muss. Themenfelder und Verfahrenstypen nennt man das.
Genau. Wobei die Piratenpartei das halt so macht, dass die Mitglieder auch tatsächlich Änderungen an diesen Verfahrensparametern beschließen können. Also auch die Verfahrensparameter sind halt irgendwo demokratisch legitimiert.
Das heißt auch sozusagen, dass das Miteinander innerhalb des LiquidFeedback-Systems ist auch selber durch LiquidFeedback gesteuert?
Genau. Es wird zwar momentan in der Software nicht automatisch umgesetzt, das müssen dann die Administratoren tun. Aber wenn es dann eine Abstimmung gibt, wir wollen jetzt das Verfahren Satzungsänderungen bitte drei Wochen verlängern, dann stellen die Administratoren das halt ein.
Okay. Aber jetzt, wenn man es jetzt mal wieder simplifiziert und sagt, hier Kegelslob alle neuner, da brauche ich jetzt gar nicht so große Verfahrenstypen, sondern die würden sich vielleicht wirklich nur unterscheiden in Schnellentscheidungen.
Und normale.
Wir müssen innerhalb von einer Woche hier auf den Punkt kommen oder langfristige Planungen, ja, wann renovieren wir unsere Kegelbahn, machen wir es überhaupt, da denken wir jetzt mal ein paar Monate drüber nach.
Also im einfachsten Fall kann man auch einfach ein Verfahren ziehen.
Und dieses Quorum, was du erwähnt hast, ist das jetzt auch Teil dieses Verfahrenstyps?
Ja, das ist auch Teil des Verfahrenstyps. Und zwar ist es so, dass man ja in einer größeren Organisation auch damit rechnen muss, dass einfach viele unausgegorene Anträge, die vielleicht überhaupt nicht der Mehrheitsmeinung entsprechen, eingestellt werden. Und damit muss das System natürlich umgehen können. Und deshalb ist es so, dass nach einer bestimmten Frist, zum Beispiel sieben Tage, wenn nach sieben Tagen nicht beispielsweise zehn Prozent der Leute, die sich für diesen Themenbereich eingetragen haben, dass sie da Interesse haben, wenn nicht zehn Prozent dieser Leute einen Antrag innerhalb von sieben Tagen unterstützen, dann fliegt er einfach wieder raus automatisch.
Von Leuten, die sich in dem Themenbereich... Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich einen Account habe in dem System, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass ich mich überhaupt in einem Themenfeld engagiere. Ich muss mich für dieses Themenfeld überhaupt erst mal melden und sagen...
Du kannst dich anmelden und sagen...
Ich will hier Teil der Masse sein.
Genau, genau.
Und in dem Moment ist sozusagen auch meine Stimme relevant für solche Quoren.
Genau.
Und das heißt, ein Antrag, der irgendwann mal abgestimmt werden soll, der muss überhaupt erst mal, man kann es so einstellen, dass er überhaupt erst mal ein gewisses Minimum an genereller Unterstützung erfahren muss.
Das sagt aber noch nichts darüber aus, wie ich letzten Endes am Ende dafür abstimme.
Ja, genau.
Das ist noch mal eine separate Meinungsäußerung. Das ist sozusagen mehr so dieses, ich würde es als wertvoll erachten, dass man darüber abgestimmt wird, auch wenn ich dagegen bin. Kann man das so sagen?
In der Regel würdest du keine Anträge unterstützen, gegen die du bist, aber du kannst dich jederzeit später auch nochmal oben entscheiden.
Man kann das ja auch so ganz offen sehen und sagen, ich bin da derzeit zwar anderer Meinung, aber wenn man sich rausstellen sollte, ich finde es mal wert, dass darüber abgestimmt wird, weil wenn sich rausstellt, dass es alles ganz anders aussieht, dann bin ich auch bereit da.
Wobei eben die Anträge auch nicht für sich alleine stehen, sondern es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, Alternativen gegeneinander zu stellen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Antrag einstellst, steht er erstmal für sich alleine. Und jeder hat die Möglichkeit, eine Alternative danebenzustellen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt irgendein Antrag zum Thema Urheberrecht eingestellt wird, der dir nicht gefällt, aber du der Meinung bist, dass das Thema ja irgendwie schon wichtig ist, kannst du halt deinen eigenen Standpunkt als Gegenantrag dazu formulieren.
Der sich dann sozusagen explizit auf die anderen bezieht.
Genau.
Die dann so eine lokale Gruppe bilden.
Und in dieser ersten Phase, nach der die Anträge aussortiert werden, ist es so, dass eben ein Antrag aus der Antragsgruppe der Anträge eben dieses Quorum erreichen muss. Dann wird das gesamte Thema als diskussionswürdig eingeführt.
Ah, verstehe. Das heißt auch, wenn ich sage, das ist ja totaler Quatsch, aber da muss mal darüber entschieden werden. Ich will aber jetzt nicht, dass es in dem Sinne entschieden wird, sondern ich gehe gleich dagegen und sage, ihr habt's ja nicht mal alle, ich fordere jetzt mal genau das Gegenteil. Genau. Und dann kann es sein, dass eben viele andere Leute auch sagen, ja genau hier das Gegenteil, das ist ja genau das, worüber wir hinwollen, und unterstützen sozusagen das. Das bedeutet dann, dass dann automatisch über alle Anträge auch dann entschieden wird. Also auch einer, der sozusagen eigentlich gar kein Quorum erhalten hätte, wird durch diesen Gegenantrag unter Umständen überhaupt erst auf diesem Quorum-Level gehoben.
Bei diesem ersten Quorum ja. Also in die Diskussionsphase gehen dann alle Anträge, wobei die Anträge vor der Abstimmung nochmal ein zweites Quorum überschreiten müssen.
Also wie viele Phasen gibt es? Drei.
Also es gibt insgesamt vier Phasen. Die erste Phase ist eben, die heißt bei uns Phase Neu. Da landen erstmal alle Anträge, die man neu einstellt, bis eben einer der Anträge eine Unterstützung erreicht hat, die das Quorum übersteigt. Dann gehen alle diese Anträge, die eine konkurrierende Gruppe bilden, in die Diskussionsphase. Am Ende der Diskussionsphase gibt es dann noch eine dritte Phase, die nennt sich eingefroren. Da können Anträge nicht mehr bearbeitet werden. Das hat bestimmte Gründe, damit man nicht kurz vor Abstimmung noch mal einen Antrag um 180 Grad dreht. Beziehungsweise, falls man das gegen Ende der Diskussionsphase tut, eben noch genügend Zeit ist, noch mal eine alte Version des Antrags wieder einzustellen oder darauf zu reagieren. Und die vierte Phase ist dann die Abstimmungsphase. Also neu, Diskussion, eingefroren, Abstimmung.
Das ist sozusagen der Zyklus, den man da immer beschreiten muss. Das ist jetzt auch immer so bei LiquidFeedback. Das ist jetzt auch nichts, was jetzt die Piraten so zusammen konfiguriert haben, sondern das ist das, was sozusagen diese Software denkt, wie es zu laufen hat.
Wobei man natürlich, wenn man das möchte, kann man natürlich die Parameter so wählen, dass bestimmte Phasen quasi auf Null zusammenfallen. Also man kann auch sagen, die eingefroren Phase dauert halt Null Sekunden. Oder das erste Quorum ist Null Prozent, dann entfällt sozusagen die Phase neu und alles ist gleich in der Diskussion. Aber grundsätzlich ist es halt so vorgesehen bei LiquidFeedback.
Ok, das heißt, ich muss jetzt, jetzt gehe ich mal wieder so zurück. Ich stelle hier meinen Antrag, ich als kleiner Demokratie-Neuling. Und jetzt muss ich quasi überhaupt erst mal Unterstützer finden.
Genau.
Wie finde ich die denn?
Also einmal gibt es halt die Möglichkeit, dass die Leute tatsächlich Anträge durchschauen und sich das angucken. Was gibt es im System an Vorschlägen? Und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch die Möglichkeit, dass du außerhalb des Systems einfach auch Werbung für deinen Antrag machst. Also zum Beispiel auf Twitter. Also bei der Piratenpartei wurde Twitter halt sehr viel benutzt, um tatsächlich auch Leute einfach auf Dinge aufmerksam zu machen. Oder halt eben auch dann auf Mailinglisten. Der Vorteil hier ist eben, dass man auf der Mailingliste eben, dass man die Mailingliste für die Ankündigung benutzt. Da ist irgendwas Spannendes und die Leute eben darauf aufmerksam macht, aber eben nicht auf der Mailingliste entscheidet.
Das heißt, das Feedback-System selber sieht auch überhaupt keinerlei Fähigkeiten vor, zu diskutieren?
Kommt darauf an, was man unter Diskussion versteht. Also die Diskussion in Liquid Feedback, also es findet durchaus auch eine Diskussion in Liquid Feedback statt. Die sieht aber nicht so aus, dass Person A irgendwas sagt, Person B antwortet, Person A wieder was sagt, Person B wieder antwortet und es so ein Ping-Pong-Spiel ergibt, wie das auf Mailinglisten auf der Fall ist, sondern Liquid Feedback arbeitet eigentlich darauf hin, dass Person A irgendeinen Standpunkt ausarbeitet, Person B einen Gegenstandpunkt ausarbeitet, Person A dann wiederum guckt, was hat da Person B geschrieben und seinen eigenen Standpunkt verbessert. Und der Unterschied zur Mailingliste ist eben, dass das Ergebnis dieser Arbeit in einem einzigen Dokument, in einem einzigen Text zu finden ist, der eben daraufhin arbeitet, dass es wird daraufhin gearbeitet, dass sich dieser Text verbessert und einen in sich geschlossenen Standpunkt darstellt. Und das ist eben der Unterschied zur Mailingliste. In der Mailingliste habe ich halt einen zerfaserten Dialog zwischen verschiedenen Leuten, während ich bei LiquidFeedback eben am Ende ein Statement habe, ein geschlossenes.
Und das sind jetzt diese Anträge selbst, die ich immer wieder ändere?
Genau.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo jemand davor kommt mit Ihr seid alle doof, wir werden alle sterben, deswegen müssen wir jetzt sinnlose Dinge tun. Dann halte ich dagegen und sage, na ja, ganz so hart muss man da ja jetzt nicht rangehen. Dann besteht quasi der Diskurs da drin. Also einer von den beiden muss erst mal genug Unterstützer finden. Das heißt, irgendwo kann man sich die Dinge ankricken und sagen, ich unterstütze, dass darüber abgeschüttet wird. Und dann kommt die zweite Phase, die hieß nochmal wie? Neue?
Diskussion.
Diskussion. Und das heißt, diese Diskussionsthase, das ist das, was du jetzt gerade meintest.
Genau.
In dem Moment, wo die Anträge quasi sich vom Steg da losgemacht haben und irgendwie frei auf den See treiben, in dem Moment kann ich dann jeden dieser Anträge modifizieren, um mich quasi anderen Leuten da anzubiedern.
Also deine Anträge kannst du modifizieren.
Aber immer nur meine.
Genau.
Oder Leuten, denen ich explizit erlaubt habe, das auch zu tun. Das war das, was du ja eingangs gesagt hast. Das heißt, ich kann auch eine kleine Gruppe von Leuten haben. Und wir sind jetzt sozusagen was. Aber es gibt immer so einen Owner. Es gibt immer so eine Person, die erstmal im Wesentlichen als...
Also wenn man mehrere Owner hat, sind die alle gleichberechtigt. Also so...
Ja, so ist es auch im System. Aber man sieht immer, wer das initiiert hat oder so.
Man sieht halt, wer den konkreten Textentwurf geschrieben hat.
Das heißt, die Idee ist sozusagen, dass man an der Stelle sich dann lieb hat und versucht, einen Konsens zu erreichen. So nach dem Motto, wir liegen ja soweit gar nicht auseinander.
Nein, nicht unbedingt einen Konsens. Es kann halt auch so aussehen, dass eben beide Seiten sozusagen Argumente aufstapeln. Also Person A baut Argumente für irgendetwas immer weiter aus. Person B arbeitet die Argumente gegen irgendetwas weiter aus. Also der Antrag besteht halt aus dem Antrag...
Um sozusagen mehr Unterstützer zu bekommen.
Genau, um mehr Unterstützer zu bekommen. Und die Argumente werden halt dann jemandem, der neu in das System reinkommt, der muss sich halt eben nicht durch ellenlange Mailing-Distance-Threads durchlesen, sondern der bekommt halt eben sozusagen auf dem Silbertablett......tour dies weil sowieso.
Und wie... So am Anfang hieß das ja, ich unterstütze das sozusagen, dass das überhaupt diskutiert wird. Und in dieser Diskussionsphase spielt das aber keine Rolle mehr.
Doch, also diese Unterstützung ist die gleiche. Also die Unterstützung in der Phase neu und in der Diskussionsphase... Also im Prinzip unterscheiden sich auch die Phase neu und in Diskussionen nicht. Der einzige Unterschied ist, dass sozusagen alles, was in der Phase neu ist, halt noch abgebrochen werden kann.
Also auch sozusagen meine initiale Unterstützung, die überhaupt erst mal dazu da ist, das Quorum zu überschreiten, ist dann ab dem Moment, wo es überschritten ist, eine reale Unterstützung dieses Antrags. So dass eben, weil ich ja am Anfang sagte, naja, ich will ja nur, dass da überhaupt darüber mal entschieden wird, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich diese Unterstützung so gar nicht geben, weil ich ja dann quasi ab dem Moment, wo es eine Diskussion ist, auch als echter Unterstützer da stehe.
Ja, genau. Also du würdest tatsächlich nur die Anträge unterstützen, die du auch stützenswert findest.
Okay, gut. Das heißt, es müsste dann auch erst ein Gegenantrag da sein, der mir besser gefällt, damit ich da wirklich zu dem Quorum beitrage, was dann im Umkehrschluss die Konsequenz hat, dass eben etwas, was einfach gar nicht so viele Leute findet, die überhaupt das erstmal toll fänden, dass unter Umständen dieses Quorum nie überschritten wird. Was sind so eure Erfahrungen? Wie viel Prozent der Anträge da durchfallen?
Also wir hatten jetzt ein Quorum von 10 Prozent im Landesverband Berlin und ich habe jetzt die aktuellen Zahlen nicht, aber ich schätze mal, dass es die Anträge, die durchfallen, sind unter 10 Prozent. Also das, was in Berlin tatsächlich eingestellt wurde, wurde dann auch diskutiert und abgestimmt in der Regel.
Und was sind das für Anträge, diese 10 Prozent, die die 10 Prozent nicht schaffen?
Entweder Sachen mit sehr exotischen Standpunkten, sage ich mal, oder auch teilweise nörgelnde Beiträge oder sowas in der Art. Also das wird dann eingestellt und es verschwindet dann auch wieder.
Verschwindet im Sinne von wirklich...
Es wird nicht gelöscht, es rutscht halt in die Kategorie abgebrochen. Man kann es auch einsehen hinterher, man kann auch noch die Unterstützer sehen.
Also schon auch eine ewige Liste aller Anträge.
Wobei man natürlich sich als Organisation auch entschließen kann, Sachen zu löschen. Also das wurde auch in der Piratenpartei diskutiert, man soll es nicht ewig speichern und so weiter. Also das ist dann natürlich die Frage der Organisation, was will die? Ich bin der Meinung, man sollte es veröffentlichen als Partei und halt auch längerfristig einsehbar machen. Aber da gibt es halt unterschiedliche Auffassungen zu.
Kommen wir wieder zurück zu meinem Antrag, der unter Umständen auch einen Gegenantrag gefunden hat. Und es kann ja auch nicht nur einen Gegenantrag geben, sondern es kann im Prinzip beliebig viele Gegenanträge geben. Also ich sage A und jemand anderes sagt, ne, A so ja nun gar nicht, sondern hier B und dann kommt irgendwie C und sagt hier C. Ihr habt es ja nicht mal alle. Aber die sind sozusagen in einer Gruppe zusammengeschlossen. Das System weiß, diese Anträge beziehen sich aufeinander.
Genau.
Wenn auch nur einer von denen genug Quorum hat, dann werden alle anderen auch mit in diesen Diskussionsmodus gebracht. Aber jeder Antrag findet für sich separat quasi Unterstützer.
Aber es ist klar, dass wenn ich einen von den drei jetzt unterstütze, dass ich keinen der anderen unterstützen kann? Ich muss mich auf einen festlegen?
Nein, in der Diskussionsphase kannst du so viele Anträge einer Gruppe unterstützen, wie du willst. Das entspricht dem Approval Voting im Prinzip. Approval Voting heißt, dass du entweder sagen kannst, ich stimme zu oder ich stimme nicht zu. Und das kannst du für jeden Antrag machen.
Sodass man sozusagen im Wesentlichen die ausschließt, die man nun wirklich gar nicht er tragen kann. Aber dass man die anderen sagt, das könnte in die richtige Richtung gehen, das könnte auch in die richtige Richtung gehen.
Wo du die Grenze eben ziehst, bleibt dir überlassen. Also in der Regel hast du eigentlich eine Präferenzreihenfolge. Wenn da fünf Anträge sind, A ist dir am liebsten, dann kommt B, C, D, E, F oder so. Und wie weit du dann gehst mit deiner Unterstützung, ob du nur A unterstützt oder A und B oder A, B und C, das bleibt erst mal in der Diskussionsphase dir überlassen.
Okay, das heißt, ich habe da keine Reihenfolge. Ich kann nicht sagen, B gefällt mir besser als C, ich kann nur sagen, ich kann mit beiden in irgendeiner Form leben, aber wie meine persönliche Reihenfolge ist, das sage ich dem System gar nicht oder kann ich dem System auch gar nicht sagen?
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht. Es hat auch wichtige Gründe. Das hängt halt mit taktischen Abstimmungsverhalten zu tun. Das wird deshalb aus diesem Grunde in der Diskussionsphase noch nicht abgefragt. Also ganz konkret...
Taktisches Abstimmungsverhalten.
Also es ist halt so, dass man bei Wahlen und Abstimmungen grundsätzlich das Problem hat, dass wenn sie offen sind, also offen in dem Sinne, dass während die Abstimmung läuft, man schon sieht, wie die anderen abstimmen, dass man dann das eigene Abstimmungsverhalten daran anpasst. Das ist ja auch der Grund übrigens, warum bei Bundestagswahlen die Veröffentlichung von Zwischenergebnissen tatsächlich auch gesetzlich verboten ist, weil es eben dieses Problem der Beeinflussung gibt. Der theoretische Hintergrund wurde schon, ich glaube, 1951 entdeckt. Das nennt sich das Allgemeine Unmöglichkeitstheorien bzw. Arrow-Theorien. Da wurde halt wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen bzw. mathematisch nachgewiesen, dass eben ein Wahlverfahren bestimmte Eigenschaften, die perfekt wären, nicht erfüllen kann. Und im Prinzip ist das halt der Grund, warum man auch diese Exitproblematik hat, dass man eben die Zwischenergebnisse nicht veröffentlicht. Bei LiquidFeedback ist es aber ja nun so, dass sie veröffentlicht werden in der Diskussionsphase. Also in der Diskussionsphase sieht man tatsächlich, wie die Tendenz ist. Aber damit das Ganze eben in der Endabstimmung nicht zu einem taktischen Verhalten führt, gibt es da halt erstmal nur Unterstützung oder nicht Unterstützung. Und es gibt halt auch noch die Möglichkeit, dass in der Endabstimmung man sich umentscheidet oder dass auch in der Endabstimmung sich noch mehr Leute beteiligen, als es in der Diskussionsphase der Fall war. Also der Trick hierbei ist sozusagen, dass ich sowohl ein dynamisch lebendes System habe, wo ich mal schon gucken kann, wie entwickelt sich das, aber trotzdem sozusagen das Problem der Wahlmanipulation durch Taktik vorbeuge sozusagen.
So ein bisschen wie bei dieser Kindersendung, eins, zwei oder drei, wo sie dann immer von diesen Feldern hin und her springen und im letzten Moment dann sozusagen auf ihre eigentliche Wahl wechseln.
Ja, es ist halt nicht ganz so krass, aber das ist vielleicht ein ganz nettes Bild dazu.
Okay. Zurück zu meinem tollen Antrag. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt irgendwie zwei Gegenanträge oder Alternatoren. Also heißt das Gegenantrag oder sind einfach weitere Anträge im Pool?
Also es heißt, glaube ich, Alternative Initiative.
Okay, eine Alternative Initiative. Das ist auch sehr moderat formuliert. Genau, sagt man Gegenantrag. Aber okay, es kann ja auch einfach sein, dass es einfach mehrere nicht wirklich ineinander Konkurrenz, also nicht unbedingt gegeneinander gerichtete Wege gibt, sondern einfach nur unterschiedliche Lösungen und man sammelt das.
Und unter Umständen könnten die sich halt auch tatsächlich nur um wenige Details unterscheiden. Also ich hatte ja gesagt, dass eben jeder Initiator selber entscheidet, wer den Antrag bearbeiten darf. Unabhängig davon gibt es zwar noch Anregungen, aber was letztendlich in einen Antrag reinkommt, entscheidet der Initiator. Das kann natürlich dazu führen, dass eben auch sehr ähnliche Anträge dann entstehen, weil jemand halt irgendeine Kleinigkeit geändert haben möchte, der Initiator sich aber querstellt. Diese Änderung aber vielleicht jemandem sehr wichtig ist und er sagt, ok, dann mache ich halt einen eigenen Vorschlag, wo eben diese Änderung berücksichtigt ist.
Gibt es auch so Konstellationen, dass dann irgendwie die Antragssteller dann gegenseitig das Editieren in ihren Anträgen irgendwie freischalten, dass irgendwie so A, B und C alle...
Ich weiß nicht genau, was du meinst, aber es gibt halt schon Leute, die sich als Gruppe einfach zusammenfinden und als Gruppe auftreten und eben...
Aber die alternativen Anträge schließen, sind da meistens, also wer den einen bearbeiten darf, der ist in der Regel bei den anderen nicht dabei.
Also in der Regel ist es halt immer ein Antragsteller. Also die Regel, manchmal gibt es halt auch Gruppen von bis zu 10 oder 15.
Macht ihr da eigentlich so richtig Statistiken? Ich meine, das gibt ja eigentlich eine ganze Menge her, so dieses System, was irgendwie alles weiß.
Also es gibt, ich glaube, es gibt so einen Artikel LiquidFeedback in Zahlen, der war auf dem Berliner Piratenblog, berlin.piratenpartei.de, ist aber jetzt schon etwas her, ich glaube, ein, zwei Monate, ein, zwei, drei Monate.
Und da habt ihr das mal gemacht.
Ja. Da haben wir mal eine Auswertung gemacht.
Also jetzt ist der Antrag in Diskussion. Jetzt findet er irgendwie Unterstützer. Die alternativen Anträge zu meinem Antrag finden auch ihre Unterstützer. Da geht es jetzt irgendwie so hin und her. Was ist jetzt so eine typische Laufzeit, die sich so bewährt hat für so etwas? Ich meine, man muss ja auch in der Zeit laufen lassen, damit es die Möglichkeit hat, überhaupt Interesse an sich zu ziehen.
Wir haben jetzt in Berlin, glaube ich, eine Diskussionsphase von 30 Tagen. Davor kommt halt noch die Phase neu, die bis zu 7 oder 14 Tage, glaube ich, geht. Also ich sage mal so in der Größenordnung von einem Monat oder so. Für die Diskussionsphase dann vielleicht noch mal ein halber Monat eingefroren. Ich denke, dass sobald die Anträge noch etwas komplexer werden, man diese Zeit wahrscheinlich auch etwas verlängern muss noch. Vielleicht auch ein ganz interessanter Aspekt noch im Gegensatz zu einer Versammlung. Dadurch, dass es halt eben in Liquid Feedback oder überhaupt in solchen Tools länger zur Diskussion steht, bietet das natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, tatsächlich Hintergrundrecherchen zu machen. Also wenn du in einer Versammlung sitzt und eigentlich kannst du in der Versammlung gar nicht mehr recherchieren, was steckt da nun hinter, wenn irgendjemand steht auf und bringt irgendein Argument und stellt irgendeine Behauptung in den Raum, dann ist es halt sehr schwierig in der Zeit bis zur eigentlichen Abstimmung dann tatsächlich diese Behauptung auch zu evaluieren. Und nachzuvollziehen, stimmt das jetzt eigentlich, was da gesagt wird, dass Antrag XY gegen Gesetz Z verstößt? Und dadurch, dass du halt eben, wenn du es in Liquid Feedback machst, das Ganze eben sich über mehrere Wochen hinzieht, steht es halt da drin. Du kannst halt recherchieren, wenn du irgendwie was findest, was gegen irgendetwas spricht, stellst du halt einen Gegenantrag und sagst, das geht aber so nicht. Oder gibst du eine Anregung einem Initiatoren, ändert doch bitte das und das, damit das Ganze funktioniert. Also im Prinzip, dadurch, dass halt mehrere Sachen parallel bearbeitet werden, diese aber dann eben eine wesentlich längere Zeit auch tatsächlich zur Diskussion stehen, gibt es halt auch Möglichkeiten, besser Hintergrundrecherchen durchzuführen zu Themen.
Ja, so das heißt, jetzt läuft mein Antrag und über mehrere Wochen. Jetzt habe ich irgendwie diverse Unterstützer und ich habe irgendwie alle Social-Media-Networks und sonstige Möglichkeiten für mein Ding zu werben genutzt. Und Leute werden darauf aufmerksam und finden das gut oder nicht gut. Aber was für eine Dynamik kann und soll sich jetzt da an der Stelle entwickeln? Ich meine, es ist ja möglich, dass die Anträge sich ändern. Tun sie das dann auch in der Regel? Ist das sozusagen der normale Weg? Oder bleiben sie in der Regel erstmal so, wie sie gestellt wurden? Was entfaltet sich da?
Es kommt eigentlich darauf an, wie komplex die Fragen sind. Also wenn es halt eine einfache Ja-Nein-Entscheidung ist, wo man halt auch nicht viel mehr Möglichkeiten hat als zu sagen Ja oder Nein, da werden sich die Anträge halt in der Regel nicht sehr viel verändern. Abgesehen vielleicht von dem ein oder anderen Argument, was noch aufkommt. Wenn es aber halt um komplexere Fragen geht, wie zum Beispiel eine Satzung, dann gibt es halt ganz erhebliche Änderungen tatsächlich auch in dem Prozess. Und ja auch bis hin zu Alternativen, die dann einfach eingestellt werden, weil es irgend wem halt nicht schmeckt. Und ja, also da kann halt sehr viel passieren tatsächlich in der Diskussionsphase.
Aber die Zeit läuft sozusagen. Was dann innerhalb dieser Phase dann nicht passiert, das findet dann auch keine Berücksichtigung. Oder kann man auch sagen, es gibt hier einen besonderen Grund, warum die Diskussion noch länger fortgeführt werden sollte?
Also es gibt ein Feature zurzeit noch in der Software, das nennt sich später abstimmen, was die Abstimmung halt verschieben soll. Das funktioniert derzeit nur, wenn eine absolute Mehrheit der am Themenbereich Interessierten das auswählt. Das ist bisher kaum genutzt worden. Eventuell...
Ist die Hürde zu hoch auch?
Ja, also unabhängig davon besteht aber jederzeit natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, einen Antrag zu stellen, dass man zu diesem Zeitpunkt keine Entscheidung will. Also wenn man tatsächlich zu dem Schluss kommt, wir finden hier irgendwie keinen Konsens oder wir brauchen irgendwie noch viel länger, um das zu recherchieren, kannst du natürlich auch jederzeit einen begründeten Antrag stellen, gar nichts zu entscheiden.
Sozusagen als weitere Alternative.
Genau.
Dem sich dann wiederum alle anschließen.
Genau, genau.
Und der dann... Und dann geht es aber in diese Entscheidungsphase auch über.
Genau, das geht dann am Ende in die Entscheidungsphase. Und dann kann man auch in der Entscheidung... Also ich will jetzt nicht vorgreifen, aber muss ich jetzt eigentlich... In der Endabstimmung gibt es halt ein Präferenzwahlverfahren. Das heißt, wenn es dort eine Initiative gibt, die sagt, später abstimmen, ich kann dann auch dafür stimmen, später abzustimmen. Ich kann dann aber auch Ersatzstimmen vergeben, wenn eben das später abstimmen keine Mehrheit findet, was ich dann anstattdessen will.
Okay, aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal kurz bei dieser Diskussionsphase. Weil die scheint ja dann eigentlich erst mal die spannendste... Also gut, im Spanzen ist immer die Abstimmung, aber inhaltlich am Spanzen die Phase.
Dies halt auch dahin geht natürlich am wichtigsten, als es bei LiquidFeedback eben die Dinge, die zur Abstimmung gestellt werden, eben nicht vorgegeben werden von irgendwem, sondern eben erarbeitet werden von den Leuten in einem vollkommen gleichberechtigten Prozess. Also das ist auch ein ganz wesentliches Merkmal, deswegen ist es auch eigentlich kein E-Voting in dem Sinne, weil bei E-Voting stünden bestimmte Optionen zur Auswahl. Bei LiquidFeedback ist die Anzahl der Optionen überhaupt nicht vorgegeben. Und das macht auch die Diskussionsphase eben sehr wichtig, sehr zentral.
Wie ist denn diese alternativen Anträge? Können denn auch zu dieser Diskussionsphase noch welche hinzukommen? Oder muss alles erst mal in dieser neuen Phase, bis das Quorum gefunden ist, müssen da sozusagen überhaupt erst mal alle zusammenkommen?
Alternativen können jederzeit dazukommen bis zur Abstimmungsphase.
Also in der ganzen Diskussionsphase kann jederzeit einfach einen mit reinschmeißen. Und dadurch, dass ich in so einen Pool, der eh in der Diskussion ist, reingehe, ist der auch automatisch auch in der Diskussion. Das heißt, da greift dann kein weiteres Quorum.
Genau. Wobei es wie gesagt vor der Abstimmung noch das zweite Quorum gibt.
Okay, gut. Aber so ist das jetzt erst mal. Das heißt, selbst wenn das nur mit zwei losging und einer von den beiden hat halt das Quorum erfüllt, kann es sein, dass da irgendwie nochmal zehn andere dazukommen, weil die Diskussion sich da entsprechend so verdichtet hat oder die Leute der Meinung sind, mit den beiden kommen wir jetzt so gar nicht klar, da müssen wir nochmal ganz anders drüber reden. Und es kann aber auch sein, dass einer von diesen Anträgen schlicht und ergreifend den Inhalt hat, wir sollten hier nicht drüber abstimmen. Das ist aber dann sozusagen erst mal nur ein Antrag, wie jeder andere auch, der jetzt keine spezielle Qualität innerhalb des Liquid Feedback-Systems hat, dass das so ein Showstopper ist. Gibt es da sonst noch irgendwelche Eigenschaften, die jetzt in dieser Diskussion noch zum Tragen kommen, die wir jetzt noch gar nicht erwähnt haben?
Ja, also was halt noch relevant ist, dass es halt bei Liquid Feedback eben noch ein Anregungssystem gibt, das heißt, ich kann Initiatoren Anregungen geben, was sie an ihrer Initiative ändern sollten, damit ich sie unterstütze. Also ich kann ganz konkret sagen, ich unterstütze dich, wenn du das und das tust.
Also sozusagen eine Unterstützung vor Behalt.
Genau, genau.
Ah ja, das heißt, hier Süßigkeiten für alle ist super, aber nur, wenn auch Gummibärchen dabei sind.
Ja, genau, genau.
Und dann warte ich sozusagen darauf, bis er dann seinen Antrag reinschreibt, und selbstverständlich gibt es auch Gummibärchen. Da gibt es jetzt keinen soffertäglichen Automatismus sozusagen, sondern ich muss dazu Kenntnis nehmen.
Genau, genau.
Und wie ist denn das, wenn solche Änderungen jetzt stattfinden? Wie sehe ich denn das überhaupt? Also kriege ich eine E-Mail geschickt, oder werde ich auf Twitter angesprochen, oder muss ich mich da immer einloggen und dann explizit in diesem Ding angucken? Hat sich da was geändert, mir jedes Mal noch mal alles durchlesen, oder kriege ich dann immer so einen Diff?
Also wenn du Unterstützer bist, wirst du halt, wenn du dich einloggst in das System, darauf hingewiesen, welche der Initiativen, die du unterstützt, sich geändert haben.
Aber da muss ich auch explizit schon mal unterstützen. Ich kann nicht einfach beobachten?
Nein, das ist in der Software momentan auch nicht drin. Wobei wir halt tatsächlich daran arbeiten, das Benachrichtigungssystem auszuab... also noch zu ergänzen. Momentan ist es halt sozusagen das Nötigste ist vorhanden.
Aber sowas ist sozusagen schon mal...
Das ist halt schon sozusagen am Horizont, aber da fehlt halt auch noch tatsächlich sehr viel. Aber das Notwendige ist halt da. Also sobald du was unterstützt, wirst du halt informiert, was sich da tut. Und es ist auch tatsächlich so, dass über die AP, die verfügbar ist, es schon einige andere Leute gibt, die zum Beispiel an Projekten arbeiten, dass Änderungen automatisch auf eine Mailing-Liste weitergeleitet werden oder dass es Twitter-Bots gibt, die Überänderungen im System bewiesen.
Dass man sich da einfach mit irgendeiner Software anklingen kann und sagen kann, wenn das passiert. Aber dann wäre im Prinzip genauso ein Beobachterstatus auch sehr wünschenswert, weil man will ja jetzt nicht unbedingt immer als Unterstützer auftreten und schon gar nicht mehr mit dem Bot.
Und also ein Teil wird halt wahrscheinlich auch in der Software noch fortentwickelt werden, dass es halt einfach mehr Möglichkeiten gibt, zu filtern, auch tatsächlich sich Notifies schicken zu lassen. Ein anderer Teil, wie gesagt, wird von anderen Leuten über die API gemacht. Und da passiert jedenfalls momentan tatsächlich so was.
Ok, aber wenn ich mich jetzt einlogge, kriege ich auf jeden Fall schon mal so den Service, dass alles, wo ich mal gesagt habe, das unterstütze ich. Dass mir das schon mal so besonders vor die Nase behält. Gibt es da so ein Dashboard oder was? Heißt das auch so?
Ne, es heißt, ich weiß nicht, wie es gerade heißt, geänderte Initiativen oder so.
Ich hab jetzt mit dieser Software, ich hab da ein paar Mal drunter geklickt, aber ich hab noch nicht wirklich so meine Bekanntschaft damit gemacht. Aber es ist ja auch so ein Trend, der sich gerade so durchsetzt bei Portalen aller Art, nicht wahr? Was weiß ich, sei es mein WordPress oder mein Flatter-Account oder so. Es gibt halt irgendwie immer so den Dashboard, wo man sozusagen den Überblick über alles, was mich eigentlich interessieren müsste, auf einer Seite hat.
Also momentan besteht es halt tatsächlich nur aus den Initiativen, die ich unterstütze und denen, die sich halt konkret geändert haben. Also das ist noch relativ mager. Aber...
Raum für Erweiterung. So, dann habe ich jetzt also so vier, fünf Initiativen. Und wenn sich da jetzt sozusagen an dem Antrag konkret was geändert hat, dann sehe ich genau was. Dann sehe ich dann diese Änderung als solche sozusagen. Also ich kann feststellen, ah, hier vor drei Tagen wurde das um diesen Satz ergänzt. Und dann nehme ich quasi zur Kenntnis, dass das ja meine Bedingung erfüllt. Und dann muss ich selber sagen, okay, ich wandle jetzt meine bedingte Zustimmung in eine tatsächlich, also meine bedingte Unterstützung in eine solche um.
Genau.
Es gibt keine Möglichkeit für den Antragssteller, nachdem er diese, ich meine, er sieht ja, wie ich will Gummibärchen, dann trägt er das da ein. Kann er da nicht irgendwie gleich sozusagen auf meinen draufklicken und sagen, hier, hör mal?
Ja, das ist natürlich so ein Problem. Also das geht natürlich bei Gummibärchen relativ einfach, aber sobald es halt, sobald halt die Anforderung vielleicht ein bisschen schwammiger formuliert ist und du meinetwegen die Anforderung stellst, ja, die Süßigkeiten sollen gesund sein, dann ist halt schon die Frage, was du unter gesund verstehst und was der Antragssteller unter gesund versteht. Und deshalb entscheidet hier halt tatsächlich, weil es ja auch immer unterstützt.
Ich sage nicht, dass das Thema oder der Antragssteller das entscheiden soll, dass er jetzt hier Unterstützung kriegt. Das wäre ja Quatsch. Ne, nur dass er sozusagen die Möglichkeit hat, mir das in irgendeiner Form mitzuteilen, explizit mitzuteilen, dass er der Meinung ist, dass er jetzt meine Anforderungen erfüllt hat und ich sollte mir das doch nochmal anschauen.
Ne, das ist momentan nicht der Fall, wobei du wie gesagt allgemein aufgefordert wirst, eben dir die Änderung anzuschauen, weil er ja möglicherweise der Antragssteller auch eine Änderung eingebaut hat, die den Antrag vollkommen um 180 Grad dreht, weil er irgendwo ein Nicht eingefügt hat. Also von daher solltest du den Antrag ohnehin anschauen, wenn sich irgendwas ändert.
Das heißt, das System steht in gewisser Hinsicht da auch stark in der Pflicht, würde ich sagen, Änderungen auch in einem Höchstmaße transparent zu machen.
Was meinst du genau?
Naja, also ich meine, wie du schon sagst, ein Wort füge ich ein und das Ding ist komplett gedreht. Dann muss natürlich das System es mir so einfach wie möglich machen, solche Änderungen zu tracen.
Wobei natürlich es auch kein Drama ist, wenn du deine Unterstützung nicht entziehst. Andere Leute werden dann sehen, dass du zwar Unterstützer bist, aber die letzte Version noch nicht gesichtet hast. Das heißt, du stehst halt eben als uninformierter Unterstützer dort. Und ganz wichtig ist es natürlich dann im Moment der Abstimmung nochmal zu gucken, über was stimmst du eigentlich ab. Also es ist natürlich schön, wenn du auch in der Diskussionsphase möglichst schnell auch Sachen updatest und nachträgst, wenn sich irgendwas geändert hat. Aber es ist nun auch kein Weltuntergang, wenn du das nicht tust.
Dass ich die letzte Version noch nicht gesehen habe. Das heißt, das System merkt sich sozusagen auch, in welcher Version mir ein Antrag mal konkret vor die Nase geführt wurde. Und kann mich dann dementsprechend auch darauf hinweisen, dass da noch etwas ist, was man sich da besser mal anschauen sollte. Aber das war es jetzt sozusagen. Das ist jetzt das, was das System quasi organisiert. Also nochmal. Antragsstellung kann alternative Anträge nach sich ziehen. So oder so muss der oder irgendein anderer erstmal ein Quorum erfüllen, um überhaupt in die Diskussion zu geraten. Innerhalb dieser Diskussion, was in der Regel der längere Zeitraum ist, der gesamten Lebenszeit dieses Antragswerkes, muss er Unterstützer kriegen oder sollte er möglichst viele Unterstützer kriegen, die kann er entweder direkt bekommen oder unter Vorbehalt. Diese Vorbehalte kann ich mir anschauen, kann mich entscheiden, ob ich die in irgendeiner Form berücksichtige. Und wenn ich sie berücksichtige, kann ich hoffen, dass die Leute dann sozusagen ihre Meinung entsprechend ändern und sagen, ok, alles klar, jetzt hat das irgendwie für mich die Qualität. Ich muss aber gleichzeitig darauf achten, dass diese Änderungen mir auf der anderen Seite nicht Leute auch wieder einbüßen können. Denn Leute auch so sagen, kann ich das auch umdrehen, kann ich sagen, du hast jetzt meine Unterstützung, aber ich würde sie dir entziehen, wenn du das und das wieder rausnehmen würdest.
Ja, das geht auch. Also du kannst zur Anregung, die geschrieben werden, kannst du auch sagen, wenn du das umsetzt, dann bin ich draußen. Das geht auch. Und damit hat natürlich halt eben der Antrag, der sich halt um die konkrete Textarbeit kümmert, der den Antrag entwickelt, hat halt die Möglichkeit dann zu sehen, abzuschätzen, kann ich das jetzt eigentlich machen oder ist das ein Problem?
Und wenn jetzt 20 Leute alle sich auf dasselbe beziehen, so nach dem Motto, ohne Gummibärchen bin ich raus, schreibt dann wirklich dann jeder einzelne, muss dann jeder einzelne hinschreiben, es geht mir um Gummibärchen oder kann ich mich sozusagen...
Man kann sich dranhängen.
Ich kann mich an andere dranhängen. Das heißt, ich sehe ja auch, was andere Leute quasi unter Vorbehalt Unterstützung machen und sagen, das sehe ich genauso. Das heißt, als Antragsteller kann ich dann auch gleich sehen, okay, wenn ich die Sachen mit den Gummibärchen mache, dann habe ich gleich 100 Unterstützer mehr.
Genau, genau. Und auch da vielleicht nochmal ganz wichtig hervorzuheben, dass eben...
Und kann ich... Und dann können auch andere Leute dann sich an dieses selbe Element dranhängen und sagen, aber wenn du das machst, bin ich nicht dabei. Ah, okay, gut. Also an jedem Änderungswunsch hängt sozusagen auch gleich das damit verbundene Wohl und Wehe mathematisch nachvollziehbar für den Antragsteller mit dran, sodass man dann eben auch schnell sagen kann, okay, alles klar, ich muss hier gar nicht groß den Populisten machen, sondern Gummibärchen und das Volk ist glücklich. Und dann habe ich 100 Unterstützer mehr, auch wenn ich drei wieder einbüße, diese Gummibärchen gibt es ja gar nicht.
Wenn natürlich der Antragsteller Gummibärchen überhaupt nicht mag, könnte es natürlich sein, dass er einfach, auch wenn 1000 Leute für Gummibärchen sind, es einfach nicht einbaut in den Antrag. Und da ist eben wichtig, dass jeder jederzeit die Möglichkeit hat, dann eben die Alternative einzustellen. Und das passiert auch tatsächlich, wenn sich Antragsteller entgegen einer Mehrheit weigern, dann kriegen sie halt eine Alternative dagegen.
Ah, verstehe. Und dann ist relativ wahrscheinlich, ja, dann sehen ja die Leute schon so, okay, alles klar, diese Gummibärchen-Verweigerer-Front muss aufgebrochen werden. Hier geht mit mir ein Gummibärchen, tralala, kommt doch zu mir.
Genau.
Aber da müssen die Leute sich dann auch schon so explizit, das müssen sie dann sozusagen bemerken, dass da jetzt ein anderer Antrag ist. Diese Unterstützung oder Vorbehalt, die bleiben dann an dem einen Antrag dran kleben und...
Ja, die können auch ihre Unterstützung dann komplett zurückziehen, dann verschieben sie dann halt.
Wie spielt denn jetzt diese Delegation, über die wir ja nun eingangs geredet haben und die ja ein bisschen auch so die Geburtsstunde der ganzen Geschichte ist, an der Stelle jetzt eine Rolle? Du hast ja gesagt, man kann die Delegation jederzeit, und das ist ja auch, warum dieses Wort Liquid vor allem quasi da mit drin ist, wie spielt die da jetzt mit rein? Wie kann ich jetzt meine Delegation hier zum Einsatz bringen?
Ja, also der entscheidende Punkt ist es halt, du, durch die Delegation gibt es halt Leute, die halt für besonders gut gehalten werden, über bestimmte Themen zu entscheiden, also entweder halt sachlich korrekt oder halt eben im eigenen Sinne. Die können halt eben die Stimmen delegiert bekommen, und dementsprechend treten sie dann auch mit einem höheren Stimmgewicht auf in der Diskussion. Und das ist natürlich insofern interessant, als dass, wenn man mal davon ausgeht, dass die Leute auch tatsächlich irgendwie in dem Sinne abstimmen, später, dass sie tatsächlich so stimmen, wie ihre Vertreter das wollen, ermöglicht das natürlich, dass relativ wenige Leute ein relativ valides Meinungsbild erzeugen können und sich halt nicht eben die gesamte Masse damit beschäftigen muss, damit eben ein schlüssiges Meinungsbild entsteht, sondern es halt ausreicht, wenn das halt weniger Leute tun. Und das ist natürlich ein Arbeitsersparnis.
Und sieht man dann sozusagen auch, ich meine, wenn er jetzt so ein Unterstützer ist, wenn ich da so einen Unterstützer habe, sehe ich dann sozusagen, mit wieviel Delegation-Power der sozusagen kommt.
Ja, das sieht man. Also da steht, also ganz konkret, siehst du halt ein kleines Bild, also zumindest wenn der Benutzer ein Bild hochgeladen hat, daneben halt den Namen bzw. das Pseudonym und dann steht da halt z.B. plus 30, wenn noch 30 Delegationen da sind. Du kannst dann auf die plus 30 klicken, dann siehst du vielleicht nochmal drei Personen, von denen die drei vielleicht dann plus neun nochmal haben. Also das ganze ist halt, durch den Baum kann man sich sozusagen durchklicken und man sieht halt auch tatsächlich, wer was unterstützt. Das ist natürlich auch ganz wichtig für Diskussionen, weil unter Umständen sehe ich vielleicht, dass irgendeine Person irgendwas unterstützt, was gar nicht geht. Ich kenne diese Person, ich kann dann Kontakt aufnehmen und sagen, du hast mal dir den Antrag angeguckt, da steht ja was ganz Schlimmes drin, was denkst du denn dazu? Und es ermöglicht halt auch dadurch, dass man halt auch die Menschen sieht, wie sie sich positionieren, ermöglicht es halt auch eben, oder regt es den Diskurs auch tatsächlich über das Thema an.
Verstehe. Ja, ist immer alles transparent und man kann eben auch seine Leute wiederfinden. Gibt es denn auch so Social-Network-artige Beziehungen innerhalb dieses Systems? Kann ich mir Leute als Freunde, Freunde wollte ich vielleicht das falsche Wort, aber so als Bekannte markieren, dass ich es irgendwie schnell sehen kann, in welchen Projekten, welchen Anträgen die so drin hängen?
Also es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass du dir eine Kontaktliste speicherst. Das hat halt keine Auswirkungen, außer dass du die aufgelistet bekommst, wenn du delegieren willst. Also da werden nicht alle 1000 Benutzer aufgelistet, sondern eben die, die du in deiner Kontaktliste stehen hast. Und du kannst auch noch andere Personen in deinem Profil verlinken. Aber ansonsten...
Ich kann mir jetzt nicht, was weiß ich, zeig mir die Anträge, die er unterstützt.
Das geht natürlich schon. Das kannst du aber zu jeder Person sagen. Also da ja die Daten tatsächlich alle offen sind, kannst du dir angucken, welche Anträge unterstützt Person X oder Person Y.
Ich denke jetzt jeder so im Hinblick auf dieses Dashboard, dass ich ja dann sozusagen... Was weiß ich, ich kenne halt auch Leute, die so explizite Trüffelschweine sind, die einfach auch immer so die wirklich echt interessanten Sachen da ausbaggern.
Das ist ein sehr interessanter Punkt, weil das ist auch eine Sache, die mir persönlich halt noch sehr wichtig wäre, das dahingehend zu erweitern, dass man tatsächlich auch über die Kontakte, die man hat, auch tatsächlich eben auf Neuigkeiten hingewiesen wird. Und ein Beispiel wäre halt zum Beispiel, zeig mir alle Anregungen, die meine Bekannten geschrieben haben. Was dabei halt ganz wichtig ist, ist, dass halt es gibt ja auch ja so Karma-Systeme oder Bewertungen von Kommentaren. Man musste halt sehr aufpassen, wenn es demokratisch sein soll, soll es halt nicht so sein, dass ich auch Leute durch Schlechtbewertung diskreditieren kann. Also das hat halt, es wirft halt bestimmte Probleme auf. Das heißt, wenn es eben solche sozialen Filter-Möglichkeiten gibt, dann wird es halt, zumindest unserer Planung nach, eben ein persönlicher Filter sein, den du für dich definierst. Und es soll halt nicht so sein, dass du sagst, Personen...
Ich wollte jetzt hier nicht so einen Facebook ausrufen.
Also das sind halt persönliche Filter-Möglichkeiten und da sehe ich auch noch ganz viel Potenzial, eben auch einen Übersichtlichkeitsgewinn zu schaffen.
Ja, und halt auch so Statistiken, nicht nur so ganz allgemein auf das System, sondern dass man halt auch selber einfach so ein bisschen so einen informierteren Blick auf das Geschehen bekommt, dass einem das System selbst einfach interessante Aspekte von Zusammenhängen einfach klar macht. Leute, die für sowas stimmten, stimmten auch für sowas.
Wobei es auch so ist, dass du zumindest je nachdem, wie die Software konfiguriert ist, also im Landesverband Berlin ist es eingeschaltet, du kannst dir den Datenbankdamp herunterladen. Also du kannst deinen Datenbankdamp herunterladen, wo alle Daten, die gespeichert sind, mit bestimmten Ausnahmen, darauf komme ich gleich noch in der Abstimmung zu sprechen, mit bestimmten Ausnahmen eben herunterladen. Und du kannst dann im Prinzip auch eigene SQL-Statements entwickeln, um irgendwelche Analysen darauf zu machen. Dass man das herunterladen kann, ist auch ganz wichtig. Das hat nämlich den Hintergrund, dass es manipulationssicher sein soll. Also irgendwer hat ja eben den Routzugang auf der Maschine, wo das läuft. Und der könnte natürlich nun anfangen, unterschiedlichen Leuten ein unterschiedliches Bild der Realität darzustellen. Und damit das Ganze nicht passieren kann, kann man die Datenbank halt runterladen. Also es werden momentan z.B. alle 12 Stunden Snapshots erzeugt. Und die Leute können dann halt vergleichen, ja ist denn mein Snapshot der gleiche wie der von jemandem anders oder von meinem Freund? Und dadurch wird halt eben ausgeschlossen, dass ein Administrator unbemerkt Daten manipulieren kann.
Und da steht aber dann auch alles drin sozusagen?
Da steht alles drin, mit Ausnahme eben bestimmter Profildaten, die eben als privat aufgefasst werden. Wenn du in dein Profil halt einträgst, wie dein echter Name ist, das wird nicht mit exportiert.
Das heißt, wer jetzt so Bock hat, Statistiken zu machen, der kann sich in diesem Dumpf wunderbar vergnügen und da einfach Dinge rausbauen und Sachen, Features einbauen. Ja, die man dann auch vielleicht wieder in die Software reinstecken kann.
Genau.
Ja, so, wo waren wir jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben? Also wir haben jetzt diese ganze Diskussionsphase und die Delegierung, ich weiß nicht, so richtig erwähnt, wie das mit der Delegierung jetzt an der Stelle funktioniert, haben wir auch noch nicht. Also ich kann, wenn ich dann an einem Antragspool bin, so, du hast ja gesagt, ich kann alle unterstützen oder auch keinen, so, ich kann das verfolgen.
Genau, wichtig ist zu erwähnen, also sobald du einen Antrag innerhalb eines Themas unterstützt, dann gelten deine ausgehende Delegation nicht mehr. Also sobald du bei einem Thema sagst, hier bringe ich mich selber ein, in dem Moment bringst du dich halt selber ein und deine Delegation ist erst mal für die Diskussionsphase nicht weiter von Bedeutung.
In Bezug auf diese Gruppe.
Genau, genau.
Das heißt, habe ich gerade eine Delegation gehabt und derjenige, den ich delegiert habe, hat in dem Pool irgendwie A, B, aber nicht C unterstützt und ich entscheide mich aber für B, dann fällt die Unterstützung für A dann automatisch weg.
Genau, genau. Du kannst auch ganz ohne einen der Anträge zu unterstützen einfach sagen, ich interessiere mich selber für das Thema und unterstütze keinen. Also wenn du zum Beispiel, wenn dein Delegierter halt einen Antrag der Gruppe unterstützt und du findest eigentlich keinen gut, kannst du sagen, okay, ich habe die Anträge gesehen, ich melde Interesse am Thema an, aber ich unterstütze keinen der Anträge.
Okay, gut, also diese Interessenbekundung ist sozusagen der eigentliche Punkt, wo die Delegation dann aufgelöst wird. Okay, aber die bezieht sich dann nur auf diesen Pool von, was ist die richtige Bezeichnung für diese Gruppe von Anträgen?
Das heißt Thema, also in der Software heißt es Thema. Auch vielleicht interessant, die Themen haben keine Namen, obwohl es Thema heißt. Das hat halt eben den Grund, dass nicht vorweggenommen werden soll, was eigentlich entschieden wird, bzw. mit der Fragestellung eben auch keine Einflussnahme genommen wird.
Das heißt, es gibt keinen Titel, oder?
Es gibt keinen Titel, genau. Das heißt, es gibt einen Titel der Initiativen, der Einzelnen. Und wenn du jetzt halt irgendeinen Antrag einstellst...
Entschuldigung, die ganze Gruppe hat keinen Titel?
Die ganze Gruppe hat keinen Titel, genau.
Okay, aber jeder einzelne Antrag hat sehr wohl einen Titel.
Genau. Und in der Übersicht werden halt die drei ersten Initiativen angezeigt. Die halt am meisten Unterstützung haben. Und die bilden sozusagen, die sind dann sozusagen namenswert.
Das heißt, das Ding hat einfach nur eine Nummer?
Genau, genau.
Thema, Nummer 357.
Und das hat halt eben den Hintergrund, dass der erste Antragsteller halt keine Sonderrolle einnehmen soll.
Weil er ja dann diesen Titel quasi festlegen würde und damit dann sagt...
Genau, genau. Er könnte da ja halt sagen...
Wohlfahrt für alle.
Genau.
Durchgummibärchen.
Genau. Und am Ende geht es dann aber darum, ob man irgendwie ein Filschbüffet macht. Es kann sich halt in eine ganz andere Richtung entwickeln.
Ok, verstehe. So, jetzt ist viel Zeit vergangen, es wurde viel diskutiert, Unterstützerangebote wurden gemacht, Änderungen wurden durchgeführt, woraufhin Unterstützer gesagt haben, jetzt unterstütze ich, andere haben gesagt, mach ich nicht. Es wurden Alternative-Anträge und noch welche Alternativ-Anträge gemacht und irgendeiner sagt irgendwie, ihr habt ja eh nicht alle hier, ich beschließe, dass hier gar nichts beschlossen werden soll. Und dieser ganze Pool, dieses Thema, diese Alternativ-Antragsgruppe schreitet sozusagen voran und dann läuft dieser Zeitpunkt ab. Das heißt, das Ding ist dann nicht mehr in der Diskussion und dann wird der eingefroren, hast du gesagt.
Genau.
Und einfrieren heißt, keiner der Anträge kann jetzt mehr geändert werden. Und was passiert dann in dieser Zeit noch, außer dass keiner was tun kann?
In dieser Zeit können noch Unterstützerstimmen gegeben werden oder entzogen werden. Das heißt, wenn ich sozusagen kurz vor Ablauf der Diskussionsphase halt noch mein Nicht einbaue, können da halt noch Leute darauf aufmerksam werden. Unter Umständen, wenn das halt eine sehr umstrittene Sache ist, wird halt möglicherweise auf Mailinglisten drüber geschrieben, wird getwittert, der hat das und das geändert, jetzt bloß alle die Unterstützung entziehen. Und vor allem kann ich eben noch entweder eine alte Revision des Antrags oder halt noch mal einen neuen Text einbringen wieder in das System. Das ist halt eben wichtig, weil der Antragsteller halt jederzeit die Möglichkeit, den Antrag zu ändern. Deshalb muss halt noch vor der Abstimmung eine bestimmte Zeit gegeben werden, wo man reagieren kann, wenn Antragsteller halt irgendwas Unsinniges oder vielleicht auch mit Vorsatz tatsächlich getan haben, um irgendwas zu verhindern. Also sie tun halt so, als ob sie irgendeine Idee unterstützen wollen und kurz vor Ende bauen sie halt irgendwas Böses ein. In diesem Fall muss es halt eben möglich sein, dann noch darauf zu reagieren. Deshalb eben diese eingefrorenen Phase. Ja, sieben Tage oder 14 Tage. Also muss man sich halt entscheiden, wie lange man sie haben will.
Aber das sind so die Zeiträume, mit denen derzeit im Wesentlichen gearbeitet wird, zumindest bei der Installation der Piraten?
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist sieben und vierzehn Tage. Bei bestimmten Sachen 14 Tage, bei anderen sieben.
Was dann wiederum sozusagen der Verfahrenstyp entscheidet. So, und dann wurde es gefriest, Unterstützer haben sich gefunden. Ist denn dann diese Unterstützung, ist das dann sozusagen die Abstimmung als solche schon?
Nein, das ist halt erstmal eine Vorab-Unterstützung, die halt im Prinzip hat sie zwei Auswirkungen. Einmal hat sie natürlich die Auswirkung, dass ich mit meinem Pseudonym oder mit meinem Namen darunter stehe und meinem Bild und vielleicht auch anderen Leuten damit zur Kenntnis gebe. Hallo, das finde ich gut. Und andere Leute sehen dann vielleicht, okay, also wenn der das gut findet, da muss ja vielleicht was dran sein. Vielleicht kontaktiere ich ihn auch und frage ihn dazu. Du sag mal, warum unterstützt du das? Also das ist die eine Auswirkung, halt das Soziale, dass ich eben einfach es öffentlich bekunde, dass ich etwas gut finde. Die andere verfahrenstechnische Auswirkung ist eben, dass ich damit dem Antrag über das Quorum verhilfe. Aber es hat noch keine Auswirkung auf die Frage, ob es dann nun beschlossen wird oder nicht.
Quorum ist jetzt wie am Anfang des ganzen Lebenszyklus wiederum eine Mindestunterstützermenge, die sozusagen bestimmt, dass das Ding dann auch tatsächlich darüber entschieden wird. Weil ja auch durchaus, obwohl es am Anfang genug Interesse gab, diese 10% oder wie man das einstellt, sozusagen, naja, da können wir ja mal drüber reden, dann wird darüber geredet. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass dann am Ende auch genug Leute der Meinung sind, jetzt stimmen wir auch da, jetzt fühlen wir da mal tatsächlich eine Entscheidung herbei.
Die Frage ist nicht, ob entschieden wird, sondern eher, welche Optionen überhaupt für die Abstimmung zugelassen werden.
Das heißt, jeder einzelne Alternativantrag muss jetzt quasi das notwendige Quorum haben, damit er überhaupt in einer Abstimmung zur Wahl gestellt wird?
Genau, und zwar alleine.
Und dann wird zwischen diesen Anträgen abgestimmt? Aber auch wiederum mit Approval Voting?
Nein, da ist das Wahlverfahren dann ein anderes. Das ist dann eine Präferenzwahl am Ende.
Das bedeutet, dass ich sie in eine Reihenfolge bringe, aber auch quasi mehrere wählen kann, aber nicht gleichberechtigt wähle, sondern eben mit einer Reihenfolge. Das wäre mir der Liebste, aber wenn er es nicht wird, dann soll meine Stimme quasi auf den übergehen.
Genau.
Das ist die Präferenzwahl, richtig?
Genau. Und zusätzlich zur Präferenz kannst du halt auch noch, also es gibt drei grundsätzliche Gruppen, es gibt halt die Gruppe Zustimmung, die Gruppe Enthaltung, die Gruppe Ablehnung und innerhalb der Zustimmung gibt es halt die Präferenzliste. Genauso innerhalb der Gruppe Ablehnung gibt es auch eine Präferenzliste.
Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden.
Also mal angenommen...
Bleiben wir aber nochmal zurückspulen. Dieses Quorum, wenn jetzt das Einstiegsquorum bei 10% liegt, wo liegt dann das üblicherweise?
Also momentan liegt es auch bei 10% bei den Piraten.
Das heißt, im Wesentlichen sagt man damit, das Interesse darf jetzt nicht erschlafft sein an diesem Thema.
Ja, oder konkret könnte es ja auch sein, dass, ich hatte ja gesagt, das erste Quorum von der Phase neu in Diskussion bezieht sich halt auf das Thema. Beim zweiten Quorum bezieht es sich auf jede einzelne Initiative.
Ah ja, richtig. Okay, verstehe. Das ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Aussage. Und es kann aber sein, dass einzelne Initiativen sozusagen dieses Quorum erfüllen, aber andere nicht.
Genau.
Das heißt, obwohl da irgendwie zehn Leute jetzt ihren Vorschlag in die Wachschale geworfen haben, dass in dieser Wachschale am Ende nur noch drei übrig bleiben, von denen die Leute der Meinung sind, naja, das ist jetzt auch wirklich unterstützend.
Das ist halt auch insofern relevant, als dass Leute, die vielleicht weniger Zeit haben, sich mit dem System auseinanderzusetzen, vielleicht ja auch, wenn die dann in die Abstimmung kommen am Ende und da hundert Alternativen sind, ist es natürlich überfordernd.
Das ist so eine Bereinigung, kann man fast sagen.
Spamfilter, wenn du so willst.
Macht ja auch Sinn. Das heißt, das wird dann Leuten auch vereinfacht, wie sich die Überzeugung jetzt in der Diskussion im Wesentlichen gewandelt hat. Das sind wirklich jetzt die relevanten Sachen, das nicht die relevanten Sachen. Okay, 10 Prozent. Das heißt, von den 10 bleiben jetzt irgendwie 3 übrig. Oder sagen wir mal, es bleiben 5 übrig. Und jetzt, das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, mit diesen Ablehnungsgruppen. Also, du musst mehrere verschiedene Abstimmungen sagen, was ich am liebsten ablehnen würde und was ich am liebsten wählen würde.
Also, du kannst zu jedem Antrag erstmal sagen, willst du zustimmen, willst du dich enthalten oder willst du ablehnen. Und zusätzlich kannst du halt bei allen, denen du grundsätzlich zustimmen würdest, könntest du diese dann in eine Reihenfolge bringen.
Beziehungsweise, ob ich mich überhaupt an der Wahl beteiligen will. Das kann ich ja auch noch sagen. Oder ist das dann immer eine Enthaltung?
Also, wenn du abstimmst, dann musst du zu allen Anträgen etwas sagen, wobei du halt einige der Anträge auch in die Enthaltung als Aufenthalt.
Ah, okay. Also ich stimme sozusagen über das Thema ab. Indem ich mich zu jedem Antrag, der das Quorum erfüllt hat, für die Beteiligung an der Abstimmung, dass ich mich dazu äußere in Form von Ja, Nein oder Enthaltung.
Genau. Wobei die Anträge konkurrierend sind. Also am Ende steht halt ein Antrag da, der gewinnt.
Ja, ist klar. Aber ich kann auch trotzdem sagen, dem stimme ich zu, dem stimme ich zu, dem stimme ich nicht zu.
Genau.
Und das tue ich dann aber wiederum in einer Präferenz oder wie?
Also du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, angenommen, wir haben jetzt die Anträge A bis F, dann kannst du sagen, Antrag A stimme ich zu, und zwar als Erstwunsch, Antrag B stimme ich zu als Zweitwunsch, bei Antrag C enthalte ich mich, D und E lehne ich ab und F lehne ich noch mehr ab.
Aber bei der Ablehnung gibt es jetzt keine Präferenz?
Doch, auch. Das ist auch ganz wichtig sogar, dass es bei der Ablehnung eine Präferenz gibt. Denn ja, also man kann da zum Beispiel mal das Beispiel bringen, irgendwie die Wiese neben deinem Haus soll bebaut werden und zur Auswahl steht irgendwie Park mit See, Einkaufszentrum oder Atomkraftwerk. Du willst vielleicht das Einkaufszentrum und das Atomkraftwerk ablehnen, hast aber dann vielleicht Angst, dass, wenn du nicht für das Einkaufszentrum stimmst, vielleicht das Atomkraftwerk kommt. Und deshalb gerätst du quasi in die Versuchung, dich vielleicht beim Einkaufszentrum dann nur zu enthalten oder gar zuzustimmen. Und deshalb ist halt hier auch eben bei der Ablehnung eine Präferenz möglich. Das heißt, du kannst sagen, Einkaufszentrum und Atomkraftwerk lehne ich ab, aber...
Nichts lehne ich so sehr ab wie das Atomkraftwerk.
Du lehnst schon beides komplett ab, aber für den Fall, dass es tatsächlich auf einen Stichfall rauslaufen würde zwischen Einkaufszentrum und Atomkraftwerk, dann stimmst du für das Einkaufszentrum.
Aha, okay. Also wenn ich sozusagen nicht verhindern kann...
Genau.
Dann immer noch eher das als das andere. Das heißt auch, die Ablehnung kann immer noch zu einer Zustimmung führen für den Notfall. Genau. Das wird ja ganz schön knifflig, wenn da jetzt irgendwie so mehrere Anträge, die alle irgendwie... Wie ist denn das? Also am Ende soll ja sozusagen ein Gewinner ermittelt werden. Das ist das Endergebnis der Abstimmung. Thema wird abgestimmt, es gibt einen Antrag, der kommt durch.
Und wenn ich jetzt von diesen Fünfen zwei gut finde, einen enthalten, zwei lehne ich ab. Und am Ende läuft es darauf hinaus, dass die beiden, die ich ablehne, diejenigen sind, die am meisten Zustimmung erhalten.
Bei der Auszählung zuerst wird geguckt, welche Anträge haben überhaupt eine Mehrheit. Also das heißt, es wird geguckt, bei welchen Anträgen gibt es mehr Zustimmung als Ablehnung. Und mal angenommen, nur das Einkaufszentrum und das Atomkraftwerk sind überhaupt mehrheitsfähig. In diesem Fall würden zwischen Einkaufszentrum und Atomkraftwerk die Präferenzen angeguckt werden. Und dann wird geguckt, was es lieber präferiert.
Okay, und da zählen dann sozusagen sowohl die Präferenzen der Zustimmung als auch der Ablehnung. Das heißt, wenn einer gesagt hat, ja ich bin dafür, aber vor allem will ich ein Atomkraftwerk, dann zählt das halt irgendwie da. Und wenn jemand gesagt hat, nein, aber wie ist denn dann diese Gewichtung? Gibt es dann irgendwie da so Zahlen, die dann da so ran verteilt werden und dann wird das irgendwie ausgerechnet? Oder ist jetzt nicht so ganz klar, wie sich das dann so in der Summe summiert? Also was heißt es, dass ich irgendwie eine Ablehnung erster Wahl habe?
Also es ist so, dass nach dieser Phase, wie gesagt, zu gucken, welche Anträge sind überhaupt mehrheitsfähig, wird halt eine Gruppe von Anträgen genommen. Und in dieser Gruppe, die halt mehrheitsfähig ist, also die theoretisch der Gewinner sein könnte, da wird jeder mit jedem verglichen. Also wenn du halt Antrag A, B und C hast, oder bleiben wir mal konkret, irgendwie angenommen See, Einkaufszentrum und Atomkraftwerk, dann wird halt das See mit dem Einkaufszentrum verglichen, das Einkaufszentrum mit dem Atomkraftwerk und das Atomkraftwerk mit dem See.
Verglichen auf welcher Basis?
Verglichen, das System guckt halt dieses Paar, wenn wir jeden mit seiner Präferenzliste, also wir gucken bei jedem Abstimmenden in die Präferenzliste rein und gucken, steht das eine über dem anderen oder umgekehrt.
Ja, aber wie verhält sich denn eine Ablehnung erster Klasse gegen eine Zustimmung zweiter Klasse?
Es ist halt keine Klasse, es ist mehr eine Ordnung, die du da reinbringst. Also es spielt keine Rolle, ob es an Position 1 oder an Position 7 steht. Wichtig ist, dass es halt vor etwas anderem steht oder nach etwas anderem.
Das heißt, wenn ich sozusagen in dem Moment, wo die miteinander verglichen werden, und ich habe bei beiden Ja gesagt, aber der eine hat halt Präferenz, dann zählt sozusagen meine Stimme nur für den mit der Präferenz.
Genau.
Also insbesondere ist es so, das geht sozusagen darum, rauszukriegen, sagst du jetzt Ja oder Nein und da geht man dann sozusagen für jeden die Präferenz durch. Und die Präferenz ist sozusagen nur für den einen Abstimmenden sozusagen interessant. Beim Vergleich zwei Anträge. Das heißt, da werden alle gegeneinander verglichen. Das heißt, wenn da irgendwie drei sind, dann wird entsprechend viel untereinander wie so eine WM-Vorrunde. Und dann wird quasi derjenige ermittelt, der sich am besten durchgesetzt hat.
Genau. Also im Idealfall gibt es dann einen Antrag, der sich gegen alle anderen durchsetzen kann. Es gibt da halt noch so ein kleines Problemchen. Es kann passieren, dass kollektive Präferenzen zyklisch sind. Also es kann Mehrheitsverhältnisse geben, bei denen sich eine Mehrheit dafür findet, statt des Einkaufszentrums das Atomkraftwerk zu bauen. Es gibt auch noch eine Mehrheit, statt des Atomkraftwerks den See zu nehmen. Und es gibt eine weitere Mehrheit, statt dem See das Einkaufszentrum zu nehmen.
Das ist so, als wenn in der Vorrunde jede Mannschaft gewinnt und die nächste wieder verliert. Und dann haben sie alle drei Punkte.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, inwieweit sich das auf die Vorrunden übertragen lässt.
Naja, aber so vom Bild her. Also es kann halt sein, Schere, Steine und Brunnen irgendwie.
Ja, genau. Und es kann halt sein, dass eben jeder dieser Vergleiche tatsächlich auch zum Beispiel eine Zweidrittelmehrheit hat sogar. Oder bei vier kann es halt sogar eine Dreiviertelmehrheit sein. Und das hängt halt damit zusammen, dass wenn ich Präferenzen ausdrücke, ja, ich halt nicht ausdrücken kann, wie viel mehr mag ich etwas, sondern es ist halt einfach eine binäre Entscheidung. Ich mag es mehr oder weniger mehr. Und durch diese binären Entscheidungen kann es eben halt zu diesen Zyklen kommen. Die muss man auflösen in dem Fall. Und da wird ganz konkret von LiquidFeedback die Schulze-Methode benutzt. Das ist ein relativ neues Präferenzwahlverfahren. Das wurde 1997 an der TU, glaube ich, entwickelt von Markus Schulze. Genau. Und das sorgt sozusagen dafür, dass das Ergebnis, ich sage es mal vereinfacht ausgedrückt, das wählt sozusagen das Ergebnis aus, wo am wenigsten Leute übergangen werden bei. Also in Falle von drei Optionen wird der Weg abgeschnitten, wo sich am wenigsten Leute dafür ausgesprochen haben.
Und ist das so, dass es auf jeden Fall einen Gewinner gibt oder kann es auch einfach sein, dass es einen Drawer gibt? Ich meine, wenn jetzt einfach 20 sagen, der ist toll, und 20 sagen, der ist toll, und die Präferenzen sind auch alle gleich verteilt?
Also es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten. Einmal gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass keiner gewinnt. Also wenn einfach keiner der Anträge überhaupt eine Mehrheit gewinnt, dann gibt es keine Entscheidung. Es ist auch wichtig, dass das passieren kann, weil unter Umständen kommt aus der Diskussionsphase halt nichts Vernünftiges raus.
Das heißt, es ist auch nicht mal nötig, so einen Antrag zu stellen, mit wir dürfen nichts entscheiden?
Nö, man könnte auch einfach abstimmen. Wobei natürlich, wenn du einen Antrag schreibst, kannst du ihn natürlich begründen. Das heißt, es ist natürlich für dich besser, wenn du einen schreibst und ihn begründest, weil du vielleicht dann auch andere überzeugen kannst. Aber man kann halt auch einfach in der Abstimmung alles ablehnen. Aber es kann natürlich auch passieren, dass es zu einem Draw kommt, dass es einen Gleichstand gibt. In dem Fall wird dann nochmal geguckt, ob die Verhältnisse von früher zu gegen stimmen, ob da vielleicht noch was zu holen ist. Und im Zweifelsfall entscheidet sich das System dann für den erstgestellten Antrag. Das ist insofern natürlich konsistent, als dass, wenn man den ersten Antrag beschlossen hätte und dann einen Änderungsantrag gemacht hätte, der würde halt bei einem Draw einfach nicht angenommen werden. Ja, wobei das in der Praxis halt in der Regel nicht auftreten wird. Das ist halt nur die letzte Resolving-Möglichkeit, um dann irgendeine Entscheidung tatsächlich zu haben. Das wird natürlich aber auch angezeigt im System. Also du kannst es auch einsehen, wie die Entscheidung herbeigeführt wurde. Also man kann es natürlich dann auch anders interpretieren. Aber das System hat zumindest schon mal versucht, erst mal einen Gewinner zu ermitteln. Man kann dann aber halt eben auch reingucken und zum Beispiel sehen, ob es zu zyklischen Präferenzen gekommen ist, ob es irgendwo Gleichstand gegeben hat, wie knapp das Ergebnis ist. Das kann man natürlich als Organisation, wenn man dann später entscheidet, wenn man dann noch eine zweite hintergelagerte Instanz hat, die das entscheidet, die kann natürlich solche Fragen auch berücksichtigen.
Das heißt, wenn es wirklich zu einem Gleichstand kommt, dann erzählt einfach, wer zuerst kam, mal zuerst. Das ist dann sozusagen der Last Exit.
Ja, aber nur für den Fall, dass natürlich beide eine grundsätzliche Mehrheit haben. Also nur für den Fall, dass eben, ja.
Aber es ist dann sozusagen dadurch, es ist dann einfach immer entscheidbar, weil diese Reihenfolge ist einfach gegeben.
Genau, genau.
Puh, gar nicht so einfach, wa?
Ja, es ist recht komplex.
Wie lange habt ihr denn daran gegrübelt? Das ging doch eigentlich alles relativ fix mit diesem LiquidFeedback.
Ich würde sagen, Mitte, ne Anfang Oktober, Anfang Oktober oder Mitte September haben wir so angefangen das zu konzeptionieren. 2009. Ihr Anfang Oktober. Und die erste Kurzzeile entstand, glaube ich, dann so Ende Oktober, Anfang November. Und ja, in den Testbetrieb ging es dann am 4. Januar, glaube ich schon. Bei den Piraten Berlin.
Das heißt, jetzt haben wir Ende Juni, jetzt ist das Ganze sozusagen 6 Monate im Betrieb. Was habt ihr jetzt sozusagen an Erkenntnissen gewinnen können?
Ja, also was interessant ist, dass man mal gesehen hat, wie beteiligen sich die Leute auch tatsächlich. Da hatten wir auch diesen Artikel veröffentlicht, Liquid Feedback in Zahlen, hatte ich erwähnt. Interessant ist zum Beispiel, dass sich etwa so halb so viele in der Diskussionsphase beteiligen. Also in der Abstimmung geht die Beteiligung nochmal deutlich nach oben. Also es gibt halt auch einfach Leute, die einfach nur Stimmvieh sind und die kommen dann irgendwie rein, wenn die Glocke tönt.
Wie im richtigen Leben, ist doch auch schön.
Ja, es ist aber ja auch legitim.
Die aber eine ganz andere Landschaft vorfinden, sozusagen.
Genau.
Die also schon sehen können, was ist hier diskutiert worden, die die ganze Historie einblicken können, die auch sehen können, wie sind die Unterstützer verteilt, was sind auch irgendwie hängende Unterstützer usw.
Also es ist ja auch durchaus legitim, dass eben jeder selber entscheiden kann, wie weit er mit der Beteiligung gehen will. Also im einfachsten Fall logge ich mich einmal im Jahr ein und setze meine globale Legislation. Dann werde ich halt mit meiner Stimme auch gehört. Ich kann aber eben halt auch anfangen, komplexe Textarbeit im System zu machen. Also dazwischen gibt es halt beliebige Abstufungen. Und ja, im Berliner System kommt halt auch tatsächlich alles vor. Also es gibt Leute, die delegieren halt einfach nur und loggen sich danach auch erstmal nicht mehr ins System ein. Und es gibt halt eben Leute, die ganz aktiv regelmäßig da Initiativen schreiben.
Und wie ist so die Quote von Leuten, die nur delegieren und Leuten, die selber machen? Gibt es so eine Größe wie die Delegationsquote, die Staatsquote, wo man irgendwie draus sehen kann, wie sehr die Eigenbeteiligung eigentlich...
Also die genauen Zahlen, wie gesagt, sind in dem Artikel, ich würde mal so schätzen, 50-50 etwa. Von den Leuten, die überhaupt was tun. Also es gibt auch Leute, die haben sich angemeldet und machen überhaupt gar nichts. Also die haben sich einfach nur mal einen Account angelegt, weder delegiert, noch...
Haben andere Sorgen, Kinder.
Genau, genau. Und ansonsten würde ich halt so sagen, auch 50-50 geschätzt, wie gesagt. Die genauen Zahlen weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Wobei 50-50 ist jetzt so ein reiner Gefühlswert, der, wenn man glaube ich wirklich einen Wert ausrechnet, dann müsste man ja alles Mögliche heranziehen. Man müsste heranziehen die einzelnen Themenfelder separat versus wo habe ich überhaupt eine Unterstützung geäußert und wie viel Prozent davon habe ich quasi per Delegation gemacht. Beziehungsweise wo war meine Delegation überhaupt nicht, hat überhaupt nicht gegriffen, weil auch derjenige, an den ich es delegiert habe, hat sich da auch nicht beteiligt. Aber das finde ich mal ganz interessant, wenn man da so eine Größe bilden könnte, um sozusagen diesen Delegationsfaktor zu erspüren. Sicherlich nicht einfach da hinzukommen, aber das sagt sicherlich auch eine ganze Menge darüber aus, wie aktiv letzten Endes Leute sind. Dabei muss ja auch nichts Schlechtes sein. Ich meine auch, die Delegation ist ja an der Stelle auch schon eine Beteiligung. Jetzt haben wir so viele theoretische Gummibärchenfälle hier gehabt. Was hat es denn an konkreten Themen, die mit dem System in den letzten sechs Monaten beschlossen wurden, erinnern, wo du eine interessante Dynamik feststellen konntest? Oder wo sich irgendwas besonders gut oder auch nicht so gut bewährt hat?
Also ein schönes Beispiel war die Diskussion um den Landesrat. Da gab es die Idee, dass es nochmal ein separates Organ, das den Vorstand nochmal kontrollieren sollte. Das war eine umstrittene Idee. Und da gab es auf der Mailing-Liste eine heiße Diskussion. Es gab die eine Fraktion, die hat immer das geschrieben. Und dann kam schon die nächste Antwort von der anderen Fraktion. Und es ging immer so hin und her. Und man hatte eigentlich den Eindruck, das ist irgendwie so 50-50.
Nein, doch, nein, doch.
Genau, die Partei ist gespalten. Und dann gab es eine Abstimmung in LiquidFeedback dazu. Und das Überraschende daran war, dass diese Frage, bei der man eben auf der Mailing-Liste den Eindruck hatte, gespaltene Partei, gab es ein klares Nein in LiquidFeedback, also gegen den Landesrat. Und das war für uns alle eigentlich relativ überraschend, weil uns vorher nicht klar war, wie unrepräsentativ eigentlich tatsächlich so eine Mailing-Liste ist. Und im Prinzip ist es auch leicht zu erklären.
Ihr wart wohl noch nie auf der CCC-Mailing-Liste.
Es ist natürlich dahingehend leicht zu erklären, dass immer dann, wenn die Stimmung irgendwie in eine Richtung kippen zu kippen, droht natürlich die Motivation, was zu schreiben, eben auch größer wird von der anderen Fraktion. Und das baut dann irgendwie so ein Gleichgewicht auf, was aber eben nicht repräsentativ ist. Und das war so eine ganz wesentliche Erkenntnis dabei.
Es gibt ja auch so diese Aussage, dass das System treu-resistent sei.
Ja, also das funktioniert eigentlich relativ gut, auch im Landesverband Berlin. Es gibt natürlich eben Leute, die schreiben Beiträge, die entweder halt unausgegoren sind oder halt auch...
Weil die einfach alle auf die Palme bringen sollen.
Genau, genau. Und das Schöne ist natürlich bei LiquidFeedback, wenn man irgendwas kommentieren will, also angenommen schreibt jetzt irgendjemand was Provokantes hinein, das ist in der Phase neu, es zu kommentieren, wird dazu führen, dass man potenzieller Unterstützer wird. Also ich kann, wenn ich eine Anregung gebe, fordert das System von mir, dass ich mich als potenzieller Unterstützer auch eintrage. Und wenn da so ein trolliger Beitrag ist, dann tun das die Leute auch tatsächlich nicht. Der wird einfach ignoriert, weil es eben keine Möglichkeit gibt, einfach mal so unverbindlich darauf zu antworten und zu schreiben irgendwie, das ist ja totaler Scheiß, was da geschrieben wird. Die Möglichkeit gibt es einfach nicht im System. Und das hat meiner Meinung nach auch sehr positive Effekte, weil man einfach nicht in Versuchung geführt wird, auf Trollbeiträge zu reagieren.
Aber gab es nicht auch die Möglichkeit zu sagen, ich entziehe meine Unterstützung, wenn nicht das und das, aber dazu muss man ja überhaupt erst mal Unterstützer sein.
Ja, genau. Also es ist auch so, dass man, man kann auch nicht mal Initiativen, man kann auch keinen, nicht mal Negativpunkte vergeben oder so etwas. Also entweder bist du dafür oder du sagst, du bist am Thema interessiert und unterstützt nichts oder du schreibst eben einen Gegenstandpunkt. Und ja, auch wenn du einen Gegenstandpunkt schreibst, werden sich andere Leute dann schon überlegen, ob sie überhaupt über das Thema reden wollen und da deine Unterstützerstimme vergeben. Und wenn das halt nicht passiert, dann fliegt das Thema nach sieben Tagen wieder raus und das war's.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Schlimmste für den Troll, ja? Dass man wirklich mal konkret über seine Vorschläge abstimmt und nicht nur darüber redet, weil es geht ja beim Trolltum eher darum, einfach alle Leute Kirre zu machen und die Diskussion am Leben zu halten. Das Einzige, was er eigentlich machen kann, wo er seine Thesen formulieren kann, ist, selber einen Initiativantrag zu machen, also entweder ein komplett neues Thema zu eröffnen oder bereits in der Diskussion stehendes Thema, das einfach noch mit hinzuzufügen. Und dann passiert wahrscheinlich einfach nichts, weil einfach das keiner unterstützt. Das ist nur so wenig, dass es nicht relevant ist.
Also wir hatten halt mehrere Fälle, wo eben solche Beiträge gekommen sind.
Fällt dir da ein Thema ein oder ist das alles geheim?
Nee, ich weiß jetzt kein konkret. Aber es waren dann halt Anträge, da war dann ein Unterstützer und das war's. Und dann ist die Diskussion vorbei. Eine andere Sache gibt es halt noch, das ist auch tatsächlich gemacht worden, dass halt Anregungen, also eigentlich ist das Anregungssystem ja dazu da, Verbesserungsvorschläge zu machen, aber auch da ist es halt dazu gekommen, dass sozusagen, ja...
Du meinst, das in Bezug auf LiquidFeedback selber?
Ja, nee, ich meine jetzt in Bezug auf Anträge in LiquidFeedback.
Ja, also sozusagen, wie das System funktionieren soll.
Und da ist es halt tatsächlich dazu gekommen, dass Leute das Anregungssystem dazu benutzt haben, sozusagen ihre Schmähkritik als Anregung in Anführungszeichen zu tarnen und halt eine Anregung schreiben, ich unterstütze diese Initiative, wenn... Und dann stand halt einfach aus dem Kontext gerissen eine Kritik dazu da. Die hätte eigentlich als Gegeninitiative formuliert werden müssen, das System wurde halt nicht so benutzt. Das führt halt ein bisschen dazu, dass es unübersichtlich wird in der Seite der Anregung, weil halt diese Beiträge da auch mit dabei sind. Aber auch da sehe ich sozusagen den Ausflug, wie man das verbessern kann, später dann halt auch tatsächlich bessere persönliche Filtermöglichkeiten zu machen. Wobei auch die Betonung da wieder ist, es muss ein persönlicher Filter sein, damit eben das Ganze demokratisch bleibt. Aber trotzdem muss man sagen, dass es in Berlin insgesamt sehr gut funktioniert hat. Es gab halt Trollbeiträge, aber die fanden halt einfach keine Berücksichtigung. Insbesondere, sie standen dann da, haben vielleicht in manchen Fällen halt einen Gegenantrag bekommen. Wenn es Anregungen waren, haben die Leute halt das negativ bewertet. Aber es gab halt eben nicht diese Diskussion, die man normalerweise kennt. Also es finden halt in solchen Fällen, es wird halt geschrieben und das war es dann auch. Das passiert dann halt nicht weiter. Es steht dann da und die Leute verbringen nicht ihre Zeit, damit irgendwie mit den Trollen zu diskutieren. Und das ist an sich eine sehr positive Sache. Wohingegen eben die sachlichen Diskussionen sehr wohl geführt werden können. Und sehr wohl eben Anträge sachlich weiterentwickelt werden, weil es dazu halt eine Motivation gibt auch tatsächlich vom System.
Diese Fähigkeit mit den angebotenen Unterstützungen, sozusagen zu sagen, ich unterstütze dich wenn, fallen dir da vielleicht noch gute Beispiele ein, wo das zum Einsatz kam, wo das so eine Dynamik entwickelt hat, insbesondere im Hinblick auf dieses Weiterentwickeln der Anträge. Also waren jetzt die meisten Anträge einfach nur so, wie sie kamen. Und dann wurde da nochmal ein Komma gesetzt, so nach dem Motto, wenn du die Rechtschreibung gerade baust, dann unterstütze ich das auch. Oder gab es auch wirklich so Beispiele, wo sich inhaltlich einfach eine Menge getan hat, gerade getrieben durch diese Unterstützer?
Also ein Beispiel, wo das Anregungssystem glaube ich sehr viel benutzt war, war die Satzung, die ausgearbeitet wurde. Also der Landesverband Berlin hat sich halt Anfang des Jahres eine neue Satzung gegeben. Die wurde in Liquid Feedback eingestellt. Und da gab es halt auch über das Anregungssystem Vorschläge, die dann eingearbeitet wurden. Es gab auch Vorschläge, die nicht eingearbeitet wurden, weil der ursprüngliche Antragsteller sich halt geweigert hat, das zu tun. Und in diesem Falle hat er halt auch eine Alternativinitiative dann bekommen, die übrigens auch gewonnen hat. Also der ursprüngliche Antragsteller, obwohl er diese Änderung nicht eingearbeitet hat, wurde sie in Liquid Feedback dann halt am Ende...
Hat sich einfach durchgesetzt. Wenn du nicht willst, dann musst du halt damit leben, dass eine Alternative aufgebaut wird, die mehr Freunde findet. Das ist ja eigentlich eine echte... Also was ich jetzt ganz interessant finde, du überleg grad so, was das sozusagen in dem Teilnehmer alles so bewegt. Das habe ich ja jetzt selber nicht so mitgespielt, von daher ist es immer so eine Sache, wie das letzten Endes wirkt. Aber ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass man jetzt gerade durch dieses Beispiel einfach das Gefühl hat, ich werde gehört, mein Interesse kann hier sozusagen durch. Und durchschlagen. Genau das, was ja eigentlich jetzt so gemeinhin immer in der Demokratie so als fehlend bezeichnet wird. Was soll ich wählen? Da ändert sich doch sowieso nichts. Da habe ich doch gar keinen Einfluss. Das entscheiden ja die da oben. Und die machen ja sowieso, was sie wollen. Und die haben sich ja alle abgesprochen. Wir stecken ja eher unter einer Decke. Diese ganzen Plattitüden und Gefühlsäußerungen, die man so gemeinhin hört, mal versuche zu übersetzen in so ein Entscheidungssystem wie LiquidFeedback. Dann kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das im Detail schon andere Auswirkungen hat auf die Teilnehmer. Was ist denn so das Feedback zum Feedback? Was hört ihr als Entwickler oder als Betreiber dieser Plattform von den Leuten, die das benutzen? Was sind so deren Erfahrungen?
Also in Berlin haben wir an sich sehr positive Erfahrungen. Man muss da vielleicht auch unterscheiden zwischen Mailing-Liste und den Leuten, die man im echten Leben trifft. Also auf der Mailing-Liste wird sehr viel geflamet über das System. Die Leute, die halt aber real zu treffen kommen, sehen das halt anders.
Ja, ich glaube Mailing-Listen können wir als Meinung und Auseinandersetzung echt ausschließen. Also ich weiß ja nicht, was die Hörer so für Erfahrungen haben, aber Mailing-Listen, das ist halt ganz furchtbar. Da reden halt die Leute, die reden wollen und die hören sich gerne selber und sie genießen es einfach, alle Leute aus der Spur zu bringen. Es ist selten, wirklich, es ist kein geeignetes Medium zur Konsensfindung. Es ist einfach nicht. Es sei denn, die Gruppe ist extrem klein.
Oder man kennt sich halt tatsächlich.
Genau. Wie viele Leute sind denn da überhaupt in dem Berliner System drin?
Ich glaube momentan, ich kann nur schätzen, 350 glaube ich angemeldet oder 400.
Und wie viele davon sind so aktiv?
Ich würde sagen so 100 bis 200.
100 bis 200 und davon so die Hälfte eher so als Delegationsnehmer und die andere als Delegationsgeber.
Vielleicht zum Vergleich. Also die Mitgliederzahlen der Piraten sind so etwa 854. Wobei man dazu sagen muss, dass auch im Landesverband Berlin einige Karteileichen auch noch drin sind, die halt nicht bezahlt haben, die eigentlich laut Satzung rausfliegen müssten. Das ist momentan nur so am Rande, halt auch noch so ein Diskursthema bei den Piraten, mal die Mitgliederzahlen zu bereinigen. Aber grundsätzlich ist es so, dass die Beteiligung halt etwa so ist, wie auf einer Landesmitgliederversammlung. Ja, also wie gesagt, im Landesverband Berlin sind die Leute eigentlich sehr zufrieden. Es gibt teilweise mit dem Interface, gibt es halt sehr viele Befindlichkeiten von den Leuten.
Darauf wollte ich nicht hinaus. Das ist ja sozusagen gelebte Demokratiekultur. Was nehmen die Leute damit? Was machen sie für Erfahrungen? Ist das jetzt sozusagen, dass sie jetzt sagen, ah, alles super, endlich Demokratie, mal wie ich es mir schon immer vorgestellt habe, und die Sonne geht auf? Oder ist es so, na ja, das hätte man ja auch anders machen können, oder die Delegation hat mir jetzt gar nicht so viel gebracht, oder die Delegation ist jetzt gerade das, was es für mich interessant macht, oder es ist mehr so diese Antragsvorschlagswelt. Also was erleben die Leute in der Nutzung?
Natürlich muss man dazu sagen, erleben die Leute auch, wenn sie persönlich mit ihren Vorstellungen scheitern im System, natürlich auch Enttäuschungen. Also es ist natürlich auch so, dass auch wenn das System noch so toll ist, wenn ich halt irgendwie einen Antrag einstelle, den ich irgendwie wirklich wichtig, der mir persönlich wichtig ist, und wo ich auch tatsächlich hinterstehe und am Ende dann feststelle, ich habe keine Mehrheit bekommen. Das ist natürlich ein Software-System. Nicht unbedingt die Software, aber es kann halt auch ein frustrieren, einfach natürlich. Einige Leute sagten irgendwie, Liquid Feedback ist halt ein Browser-Game. Ja, es hat halt auch so einen kleinen Suchtfaktor, dann halt auch davor zu sitzen und zu gucken, was machen meine Initiativen und so ein bisschen Farmville für Demokraten. Aber ansonsten sind die Piraten, glaube ich, schon so im Großen und Ganzen, also jetzt zumindest, so wie ich das aus dem Landesverband Berlin wahrnehme, finden das schon sehr gut, weil es sich eigentlich auch immer gezeigt hat, dass es sehr schwierig ist, auf Landesmitgliederversammlungen dann viele Sachentscheidungen durchzuführen.
Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt auch einmal gemacht worden. Also auf der letzten, wie heißt das, Mitgliederversammlung, Landesversammlung, Landesparteitag.
Landesmitgliederversammlung.
Landesmitgliederversammlung, also Wulgo, Landesparteitag. Da wurde das ja sozusagen, also noch nicht bindend eingesetzt, sondern es wurde aber von einigen genutzt.
Es wurde vor der Landesmitgliederversammlung halt in einem Testbetrieb eingeführt. Da wurden halt auch schon Anträge formuliert, wobei die halt, ich glaube, da waren keine inhaltlichen Anträge drunter bisher, die abgestimmt wurden, sondern es ging halt eher um Organisation der Partei an sich. Unter anderem halt eben die Satzung, die abgestimmt wurde in dem System. Und die wurde auch mit einer kleinen Ausnahme halt so auch tatsächlich übernommen, wie sie dann abgestimmt war im System.
Okay, also für den eigentlichen politischen Prozess in dem Sinne wurde es noch gar nicht benutzt, sondern eher noch so ein bisschen auf der Metaebene.
Zu den Sachfragen gab es, also es gibt jetzt schon Entscheidungen, aber auf der Landesmitgliederversammlung war keine Zeit mehr, um über Programmerweiterungen zu sprechen. Es ist übrigens auch ein Problem, was auf dem Bundesparteitag ebenso war, also Vorstandswahlen und dann irgendwie gab es Diskussionen um Liquid Feedback und dann war der Parteitag auch schon zu Ende. Also es ist halt auch schwierig tatsächlich so einen Diskurs auf dem Parteitag zu organisieren, wenn da irgendwie tausend Leute miteinander reden wollen.
Ja, aber ich meine, da genau soll ja jetzt Liquid Feedback auch helfen.
Genau, genau.
Es gab eine Entscheidung bei den Berlinern, Liquid Feedback sozusagen als verbindliches System einzuführen oder wie war die Formulierung?
Also verbindlich in Anführungszeichen und also erstmal wurde nicht Liquid Feedback beschlossen, sondern allgemein eben ein Software zur Meinungsfindung. Also das ist halt immer...
Die Wissenprinzip von Delegated Voting entspricht.
Genau, genau. Also es ist halt immer schwierig, sich konkret auf eine Software in Ersatzung, das macht halt wenig Sinn, sondern eben abstrakt. Und dort wurde eben beschlossen, dass der Vorstand gehalten ist, die Meinungsbilder aus dem System zur Beschlussfindung heranzuziehen. Das hat bestimmte juristische Gründe, weil man den Vorstand auch gar nicht an Entscheidungen, also angenommen Liquid Democracy, wie Rheinorgan oder so etwas, man könnte den Vorstand wohl faktisch gar nicht daran binden, so wie ich das mitgehört habe. Ich bin da auch kein Rechtsexperte, aber...
Vom Parteirecht her, weil das einfach so nicht vorgesehen ist, wieder einzuschränken in seiner...
Zumindest habe ich das so verstanden. Es gibt auch andere Ansichten, dass man das könnte, aber...
Gut, I'm not a lawyer.
Man hat natürlich, wenn man das unverbindlich macht, den Vorteil, dass man da in keine juristischen Probleme läuft. Das ist natürlich der Vorteil. Und es ist natürlich auch so, dass ein Vorstand natürlich ein Problem bekommt, wenn es einen eindeutigen Basisbeschluss gibt. Und der Vorstand das nicht tut, dann bekommt er natürlich in Erklärungsnot.
Okay, das heißt, es geht sozusagen darum, dass das LiquidFeedback-System jetzt dafür verwendet werden soll, um einfach auch konkrete politische Anträge zu formulieren, zur Abstimmung zu bringen. Sicherlich, denke ich mal, werden gerade so diese Quoren unter Umständen dann auch für wirklich wichtige Sachen auch noch mal besonders hoch gesetzt werden, um die Akzeptanz da zu fördern. Kannst du dir so was vorstellen? Ich weiß nicht, du hast mal von 10 Prozent gesprochen. Ist das generell so für alle Sachen? Gibt es nicht irgendwas, wo man sagt, da muss das Abstimmungsquorum besonders hoch sein?
Ich glaube, es gibt noch so ein Schnellverfahren für Veröffentlichungen, wo das bei 30 Prozent ist, aber ansonsten...
Also, wenn schnell, dann großes Interesse sozusagen.
Aber ansonsten, mit den 10 Prozent klappt das eigentlich ganz gut bisher.
Hätte ich mir jetzt vorstellen können, dass das noch so eine Diskussion ist, aber wie auch immer. Also, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas ganz Nennenswertes sozusagen zur Abstimmung bringe, was also jetzt, was hier lokale politische Forderungen betrifft, ja, dann... Und ich kriege jetzt die Zustimmung im System, das heißt, mein Antrag kommt dann irgendwie auch durch, dann wäre das sozusagen jetzt angeraten, für den Vorstand das einfach zur Kenntnis zu nehmen.
Genau.
Aber ich kann das auch einfach auf der Mitgliederversammlung dann präsentieren und sagen, hier, bekannt aus Film und Fernsehen irgendwie, wurde schon bei Liquid Feedback irgendwie toll dargestellt, ja, ganz heißer Scheiß, hier stelle ich euch zur Abstimmung, nehmt das doch mal.
Genau. Und der entscheidende Punkt ist halt, das Ziel ist, dass halt zu diesem Zeitpunkt die wesentlichen Argumente halt auch schon ausgetauscht sind und halt auch eben quantifiziert wurde, wie die Leute dazu stehen.
Aber es gibt natürlich dann auf so einem Parteitag dann immer wieder eine neue Diskussionsphase, die dann ja so oder so nochmal eröffnet wird, ne?
Das stimmt, das ist halt die Frage, wie man den Parteitag dann organisiert und ja, es ist natürlich auch die Frage, inwieweit die Gruppen, die tatsächlich abstimmen, identisch sind. Also wenn man natürlich Leute hat, die sich nur online beteiligen, die vielleicht auch auf Parteitage gar nicht gehen, kann es natürlich dazu kommen, dass einfach die Grundgesamtheit eine andere ist. Bisher funktioniert das ganz gut, man muss halt gucken, wie sich das entwickelt.
Ja, noch so ein paar schöne Beispiele, wie Leute ihre Anträge so durch LiquidFeedback geformt haben sehen oder die sich in irgendeiner Form konkret geäußert haben.
Also was vielleicht auch noch ein gutes Beispiel ist, ist es ein bisschen umstrittener gewesen, da war ich auch mit involviert. Da ging es um die Forderung auf dem schwul-lesbischen Stadtfest zu fordern, dass Blutspenden auch für Menschen, auch für Homosexuelle zu erlauben. Genau, wobei nicht Homosexuelle. Also Homosexuelle ist ja die Orientierung. Eher Männer, die mit Männern Sex haben. Und da wird ja unterschieden, auch bei dem Blutspendedienst. Oder zumindest ist Ziel, das zu unterscheiden, weil homosexuell kann ich auch sein, ohne Sex zu haben. In diesem Fall wäre auch die Blutspende kein Problem. Es gibt auch Männer, die mit Männern Sex haben, oder Frauen, die mit Frauen Sex haben.
Die nicht homosexuell sind.
Die sich zumindest nicht so bezeichnen. Deswegen wird halt dieser Begriff auch vermieden auf jeden Fall. Die Initiative war eben, dass man die Blutspendedienste sozusagen verpflichten sollte, diese Blutspenden auch anzunehmen. Und es ist halt ein sehr schwieriges Thema, weil es halt bestimmte statistische Erhebungen einfach gibt und dazu kommt natürlich noch, dass es ja auch eine Aufwandsentschädigung gibt und dann natürlich der Vorwurf der Diskriminierung da ist und so weiter. Auf jeden Fall gab es halt eben die Forderung auf dem Stadtfest eben in den Flyer, die Forderung aufzunehmen, dass eben eine Blutspende angenommen werden muss, auch eben von Männern, die mit Männern Sex haben. Und da wurde halt verwiesen auf eine Webseite, die halt dazu was geschrieben hat. Und es war zuerst halt sehr beliebt, diese Initiative auch tatsächlich. Und ja, ich habe dann aber eine Gegeninitiative geschrieben, wo ich halt eben auf die Risiken, auf die Statistiken vom Robert-Koch-Institut hingewiesen habe und auch so ein bisschen die Quellen, die von der anderen Initiative kamen, so ein bisschen in Frage gestellt und auseinandergenommen habe und hinterfragt habe. Und das hat tatsächlich das Meinungsbild komplett umgekippt und es gab am Ende tatsächlich die Meinung, sich aufgrund der aktuellen Informationslage, die man halt zu dem Thema hat, es eben nicht in den Flyer aufzunehmen, dieses Thema.
Was dann auch nicht geschah.
Was dann auch nicht geschah. Also die Aussage war nicht, dass man es weiterhin verbieten will oder so, aber das ist halt zumindest die Information, die man halt zumindest jetzt hat von dieser Initiative, dass die nicht ausreichen, um diese Forderung zu rechtfertigen.
Das ist natürlich auch eine schöne Entscheidungsresource. Du hast ja gesagt, das System ist quasi eine ewige Liste aller Entscheidungen und ich denke ein Problem in solchen Diskussionen ist, dass natürlich bestimmte Ideen dann aber auch immer wieder auf den Tisch gehoben werden.
Ja und es ist passiert auch, dass zum Beispiel in neuen Entscheidungen dann auch Referenzen auf alte Entschlüsse gefasst werden. Also dass du halt irgendjemand stellt was ein und dann reagiert jemand darauf und sagt, aber es gab doch schon dann und dann den Beschluss, was ist denn jetzt anders. Irgendwie hat sich die Faktenlage verändert oder? Und dafür ist natürlich auch so eine Historie sehr praktisch, dass man da halt nachschauen kann.
Ja, klingt ja eigentlich wie ein ganz praktisches Tool, oder?
Ja, also man muss...
Seid ihr zufrieden mit eurem Werk? Ich meine, als guter Po am Nier aus, natürlich nie zufrieden.
Also es gibt halt noch diverse Sachen an Erweiterungen. Wie gesagt, ich hatte diese Filter angesprochen, die halt noch interessant sind. Die API soll noch erweitert werden, damit halt auch es anderen Leuten vereinfacht wird, eben Zusatzsoftware dazu zu schreiben, Auswertetools, Benachrichtigungsdienste und diese ganzen Sachen. Aber an sich bin ich schon zufrieden, dass es vor allem jetzt einfach mal eine solche Software gibt. Man muss ja auch sagen, dass es schon ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, dass wir irgendwie im Jahre 2010 sind und es eigentlich sehr wenig Software gibt. Also warum werden Mailing-Listen so viel benutzt, tatsächlich, um sich irgendwie zu koordinieren? Es ist halt fast ein bisschen erschreckend, muss ich sagen, dass es da halt bisher noch nichts gegeben hat an anderer Software.
Es ist natürlich jetzt auch so, dass man schon ein gewisses Verständnis, wir reden jetzt hier schon eine Weile darüber, so es gibt sehr viele Aspekte, die man so bedenken muss, die ja dann auch einem überhaupt erstmal ein gutes Gefühl geben. Zunächst einmal ist das so eine Maschine und so, ich soll jetzt hier irgendwie meine Entscheidung an den Computer übergeben und dann kommen irgendwelche Leute von irgendwo und klicken dann drauf rum. Da muss man ja überhaupt erstmal genug einfach verstanden haben und genug irgendwie auch so zur Kenntnis genommen haben, wie diese Komplexität sich jetzt konkret abbildet. Ja, also allein dieses Abstimmungsmodell, was wir vorhin da durchmarschiert haben, das ist ja nicht komplexitätsbefreit. Da steckt ja schon so einiges drin und ich denke, gerade bei solchen Entscheidungssachen ist natürlich auch ein großes Vertrauen nötig. Man muss gerade in so einem System, was mir Entscheidungen letzten Endes, also nicht abnimmt, aber sozusagen die Entscheidungsfindung versucht zu automatisieren und zu beschleunigen, ist es, denke ich, sehr wichtig, dass man ein extrem großes Vertrauen bei den Benutzern aufbaut. Durch Sachen, wie wir ja auch schon besprochen haben, was weiß ich, gute Statistiken bzw. überhaupt durch das Transparentmachen dieses Entscheidungsbaums oder der einzelnen Wege. Ich meine, es ist ja auch absehbar hier, dass das ja auch Inhalt der ganzen Geschichte ist. Aber wo siehst du denn derzeit die Risiken und Nebenwirkungen, die derzeit noch da sind? Also einerseits sei es jetzt Unklarheiten, die einfach bestimmte Benutzer so nicht verstehen und sich einfach von Sachen abgeschreckt fühlen oder wo es auch wirklich noch ein offenes Rennen ist, wie man denn damit umgeht und wo sich Probleme ergeben?
Ja, also ich sehe da mehrere Sachen. Zum einen ist es auch eine Sache, die wir festgestellt haben, das System ist nicht selbsterklärend. Es gibt auch einfach, wenn man die Leute einfach davor setzt, sind die auch erst mal überfordert damit. Und es macht es halt etwas schwierig. Also konkret arbeiten wir halt daran, dass wir jetzt innerhalb der Piratenpartei so ein bisschen versuchen, Workshops zu organisieren, wie man das System benutzt, damit die Leute auch tatsächlich auf dem gleichen Niveau sind. Denn es ist natürlich auch ein Problem, wenn ein Teil der Leute mit dem System gut umgehen kann, weiß, wenn mir was nicht gefällt, dann schreibe ich eine Gegeninitiative und andere Leute wissen das vielleicht gar nicht. Die stehen dann davor und sagen, wo kann ich auf nein klicken?
Das ist ja auch bei der Wikipedia so ein bisschen so dieses, wie mache ich eine Tabelle, wie muss ich?
Das ist halt nicht selbst erklärt.
Das ist halt der sprechende Büroklammer in alt.
Ja, wir haben schon darüber geschertzt. Es gibt blaue Hilfeboxen. Ich weiß nicht, wie die Formulierung ist. Das heißt, blaue Hilfeboxen verfolgen dich bei der Nutzung von Liquid Feedback. Das ist der eine Punkt. Der andere Punkt ist, ich hatte das ja anfangs schon gesagt, die Beteiligungsschwelle wird natürlich abgesenkt. Wenn man das Ganze mit einer auch pseudonymen bzw. also anonymen, in dem Sinne, dass die Pseudonyme unbekannt sind, halt nutzt, besteht natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dass irgendwelche Leute Mitglied werden in einer Organisation und dann sich sozusagen an Entscheidungsprozessen beteiligen können, ohne überhaupt in Erscheinung zu treten. Und eine Unterwanderung kann man natürlich grundsätzlich auch nicht verhindern, aber wenn man natürlich eine anonyme Beteiligung ermöglicht, macht man es natürlich bestimmten Leuten vielleicht auch einfacher, sozusagen.
Ja, ich meine, man kann ja sagen, dass man irgendwie, wenn man daran teilnehmen will, auch einmal in einem Monat im Vereinsheim auftauchen muss und einen roten Knopf drücken muss.
Genau, also es ist halt eine Frage der Akkreditierung letztendlich. Also man könnte sich auch vorstellen, dass man sagt, dass eben die Leute, die abstimmen, sich auf den Parteitag akkreditieren müssen für das nächste halbe Jahr oder für das nächste Jahr, um zugelassen zu sein im System. Das wäre alleine schon deshalb sinnvoll, weil es ja vielleicht auch Briefkastenanmeldungen gibt. Also das Problem der Akkreditierung nimmt einem die Software nicht ab. Das muss man halt einfach tun und das muss man halt auch überprüfen. Und ja, letztendlich muss man da auch gucken, dass natürlich auch seit des Vorstands da keine Geisterkartei angelegt wird mit irgendwelchen Mitgliedern, die es nicht gibt.
Aber ich denke, das wird natürlich auch ein bisschen die Erfahrung zeigen, nicht wahr? Man muss ja erstmal schauen, man muss erstmal wahrscheinlich sich auch ein paar Bösewichte da heranzüchten, die quasi missbräuchliches Verhalten an den Tag legen. Und dann muss man sehen, wie sich das so äußert und was man dann dagegen tun kann. Also ich habe gerade in solchen Community-Systemen auch in der eigenen Erfahrung immer gelernt, dass nicht so sehr hilft wie die Community selbst. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man eben Werkzeuge zur Verfügung stellt, um so eine Art Selbstkontrolle dort auch zu entwickeln in irgendeiner Form. Das heißt nur beobachtenderweise, um so quasi so Warnmelder zu haben, so ein komisches Verhalten. Ich meine, darauf setzen ja auch viele Communities. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht ein System des Misstrauens empfehlen. Das ist nicht das, was ich meine. Also jetzt nicht so eine Stasi mit irgendwie Abstimmungsüberwachung. Aber wenn eine Organisation für sich beschließt, dass es ein Problem ist, wenn jetzt irgendwie einer reingeht, einmal delegiert und dann nie wieder was tut, dann wäre das System ja sehr wohl in der Lage, genau dieses Verhalten als solches auch einfach zu erkennen.
Ja, das kann man natürlich erkennen, aber ich glaube schon, dass man halt klare Regelungen braucht. Und natürlich muss man auch immer im Hinterkopf behalten, dass natürlich auch Sachen umgangen werden können. Also wenn man halt sagen würde, man muss sich beteiligen, das ist praktisch nicht umsetzbar. Denn da kann ich dann einfach ein paar Mal im Monat klicken. Also ich halte aber wie gesagt, das hatte ich ja auch gesagt anfangs, ich glaube nicht, dass die Lösung sozusagen sein kann, irgendwelche künstlichen Hürden aufzubauen. Wenn, dann sollte man sich als Organisation halt überlegen, ja und wie mache ich die Akkreditierung tatsächlich? Also dann würde ich halt eben eine Akkreditierung auf den Parteitag zum Beispiel machen, wenn es halt ein Problem gibt ansonsten. Da irgendwie mit der Software-Hürden aufzubauen, das ist halt eine schwere Sache, weil im Zweifelsfall ist es eine Web-Anwendung, da kann ich auch einen Bot schreiben, was tut.
Nee, das ist schon richtig. Ich meine jetzt nicht so sehr das Verhalten im Sinne von der Benutzung, sondern halt ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich meinte. Anyway, da muss man glaube ich ganz viel drüber nachdenken. Technik haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht so viel drüber gesprochen. Und überhaupt, ich meine, es handelt sich hierbei um freie Software, richtig? Genau. Die unter welcher Lizenz?
MIT-Lizenz.
MIT, also BST-Lizenz lässt sich also überall reinkloppen, ohne groß drüber nachdenken zu müssen. Wie ist denn das System mehr so auf Standalone und steht nur so für sich hin ausgelegt? Oder lässt sich das auch in andere Systeme integrieren, wo solche Benutzer konnten unter Umständen schon existieren?
Also es ist so, dass die Implementierung in zwei Teile geteilt ist. Es gibt eben den Kern, der die Abstimmungslogik, die ganzen Unterstützungen, die Phasen usw. abbildet. Und es gibt ein Frontend dazu. Wenn man die Software in irgendetwas anderes integrieren will, dann würde sich anbieten, diesen Kern zu nehmen. Also diese Datenbank, der Kern ist in Form von Stored Procedures für PostgreSQL geschrieben. Dass man diesen Teil z.B. in eine andere Software einbaut. Und diese Software kann dann die Tabellen des LiquidFeedback-Kerns beschreiben. Dort eben Sachen reingeben.
Das heißt, die ganze innere Konsistenz und die inneren Abläufe spielen sich ausschließlich innerhalb dieser SQL-Datenbank ab?
Genau, also der ganze Ablauf läuft innerhalb der SQL-Datenbank ab.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen als Kern in sich konsistent. Und von außen muss man dann...
Man muss allerdings, bei PostgreSQL, zumindest in unserer Implementation, ist es nicht so, dass irgendwie eine Zugriffskontrolle auf dem Kern basiert, sondern der Kern sorgt halt quasi nur dafür, dass die Abläufe in sich schlüssig sind, aber dass jetzt irgendein Initiator nun bearbeiten darf, das musst du zurzeit das Frontend machen.
Okay, das heißt, man muss dann sozusagen seine eigentliche User-Logik noch selber machen. Aber das ist ja auch genau das, was ich meine. Wenn man das halt in sein System integriert, wo man sowas schon hat, dann ist das ja dadurch eben auch gewährleistet. Also von daher siehst du da schon gute Möglichkeiten, dass man das auch in andere Systeme integriert. Das heißt, wer auch immer in seinem Organisationstool, wo eben die Benutzer und Mitglieder welcher Gemeinschaft auch immer ohnehin schon in irgendeiner Form abgebildet sind, gäbe es die Möglichkeit, sagen wir es jetzt als einfaches, aber es gäbe die Möglichkeit, dass sozusagen diese Abstimmungssystematik mitzuintegrieren.
Ja, das könnte man machen. Also entweder indem man das so nimmt, wie es ist, oder indem man halt vielleicht auch bestimmte Sachen des Kerns anpasst. Also das ist ja auch möglich.
Aber man müsste sich dann sozusagen noch sein eigenes User-Interface dafür bauen.
Also man kann natürlich auch unser User-Interface benutzen, aber die Frage ist halt, ob das dann passt. Die Frage ist ja, wo es rein integriert werden soll. Aber deswegen haben wir auch die MIT-Lizenz genommen. Wir möchten, dass die Software möglichst frei ist und dass möglichst jeder auch tatsächlich diese Technik benutzen kann. Und es wird sich hoffentlich alles noch weiterentwickeln. Es ist halt im Prinzip der Anfang einer neuen Klasse von Programmen, die da hoffentlich entstehen wird.
Wo geht es hin? Was sind so die nächsten Aufgaben?
Die nächsten Aufgaben sind im Bezug auf die Entwicklung immer noch das Thema, dass wir auch Strukturen von Organisationen besser abbilden wollen, also Landesverbände, Kreisverbände und so weiter, dass man halt eben auch Abstimmungen innerhalb eines Kreises machen kann, wo dann halt eben auch nur die Leute stimmberechtigt sind, die eben dort ansässig sind. Wie das halt in der Organisation auch definiert ist. Das ist der eine Punkt. Dann, wie gesagt, bessere Anzeigemöglichkeiten, also Filter, Benachrichtigungen, solche Dinge. Genau. Ja, und ansonsten wird es irgendwann auch nochmal Arbeit daran geben müssen, dass das System ein bisschen einfacher zu installieren ist. Momentan ist das noch sehr komplex. Also da muss man schon, es gibt keinen Autoconf oder so, es gibt auch keinen Debian-Package noch nicht, aber es ist halt auch eine Sache, die halt kommen sollte, damit es einfach einfacher wird, es einzusetzen.
Wie viele Leute arbeiten in dem System?
Jetzt an der Entwicklung. Also das machen wir größtenteils zu zweit bis zu dritt. Also die Konzeptionierung haben wir mehr zu dritt gemacht. Das eigentliche Coding eher zu zweit. Es gibt halt noch Kontributoren, die halt zum Beispiel Übersetzungen gemacht haben in andere Sprachen, um das Fronten halt international zu gestalten. Aber im Wesentlichen machen wir das halt zu zweit. Das System gibt es herunterzuladen unter www.publicsoftwaregroup.org. Da auf Liquid Feedback klicken, da kann man sich das herunterladen. Es gibt Tarballs und ein Repository. Im Repository kann sich halt jederzeit noch ändern. Also da muss man ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, wenn man da was runterlädt. Ansonsten würde ich halt eben den letzten Tarball empfehlen oder das Repository auf dem letzten Versionstag, den es gibt.
Public Software Group, was steckt dahinter?
Das ist einfach ein Verein, den wir gegründet haben, um unsere Software zu veröffentlichen, damit, für den Fall, dass es irgendwelche Rechtsprobleme gibt oder Ähnliches, wir halt da nicht persönlich verhaften.
Aber Liquid Feedback ist sozusagen das einzige System, um das sich die Public Software Group derzeit kümmert?
Nee, es gibt noch ein paar andere. Es gibt auch andere Projekte darunter. Aber es sind kleinere Sachen einfach.
Ok, die jetzt auch nicht unmittelbar in Verbindung stehen. Das habe ich ja jetzt eingangs schon mal versucht, mit einzubringen. Aber den Blick wollte ich jetzt auch nochmal haben. Andere Systeme, die sich dieser Problematik des Abstimmens etc. widmen. Was kannst du da noch nennen? Also Adhocracy hast du ja erwähnt als eine Variante, die auch sich diesen Delegated Voting zunimmt. Aber es würde mich mal interessieren, was du da noch für einen Überblick hast, was überhaupt so an Entscheiderabstimmungs-Tools da draußen rumfliegt, was unter Umständen interessant ist. Weil Liquid Feedback mag jetzt auch für manche Anforderungen dann auch wiederum schon zu umfangreich zu sein. Keine Ahnung, ist ja ein gewisser Aufwand. Manchmal will man ja auch nur sich darüber einigen, wann man sich trifft. Was fällt dir da so aus dem Kopf noch ein?
Mir fallen jetzt ein paar Namen ein.
Den Unterschied haben wir noch nicht so richtig rausgearbeitet.
Nee, nee. Votorola gibt es noch. Votorola nennt sich das. Was ein bisschen verwirrend daran ist, die haben auch Delegationen. Das sind aber eigentlich ganz andere Delegationen. Also da wird zwischen Anträgen delegiert. Da darf man nicht durcheinander kommen. Das ist ein bisschen ein anderes Konzept. Dann gibt es noch Kandivie, fällt mir noch ein. Das ist glaube ich so ein Wiki mit Revue. Ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt. Die Piraten benutzen dann glaube ich noch Hamburg oder Niedersachsen. Den Piratensextanten in Hamburg glaube ich. Ja, den Piratensextanten. Da werden aber glaube ich nur Optionen zur Abstimmung gestellt, wo man dann auswählen kann, was man möchte. Was ja bei LiquidFeedback gerade das Ziel ist, die Antwortmöglichkeiten selber zu erarbeiten. Natürlich muss man sagen, dass, weil du sagtest, für manche ist LiquidFeedback vielleicht auch überdimensioniert. LiquidFeedback ist vor allem darauf ausgelegt, dass Leute damit arbeiten, die sich eben auch nicht grün sind oder nicht gut miteinander klarkommen. Wenn man halt eine kleinere Gruppe ist, die irgendwie sowieso gemeinsam konstruktiv zusammenarbeitet, dann braucht man eigentlich etwas mit weniger Restriktion. Also da ist vielleicht ein Wiki sogar einfach geeigneter. Weil in einem Wiki kann ich halt, ohne dass irgendwelche Fristen laufen, ohne dass irgendwelche Quoren überschritten werden, da kann ich einfach reinschreiben, was ich für sinnvoll halte, während ich halt bei LiquidFeedback doch schon ein relativ starres Konstrukt habe. Das starre Konstrukt ist halt dann wichtig, wo eben die Leute ja, möglicherweise einfach auch mal gegeneinander arbeiten. Und daher eben auch bei LiquidFeedback die Forderung, dass nicht einfach irgendjemand irgendwas editieren darf, damit es eben dann nicht zu der Gefahr eines Edit Wars kommt, wie das eben bei einer Wiki-Seite der Fall sein kann.
Du meintest ja, dass Artocracy eben auch mehr von dieser Kollaboration ausgeht.
Ja, das würde ich so sagen.
Aber was fehlt jetzt Artocracy, dass es diesen Stempel von dir nicht bekommt?
Also ich würde sagen, das Problem ist halt eben der Frage, dass es halt nicht entschieden ist, wenn es tatsächlich einen Streit gibt, was geändert werden soll an einem Antrag, dass es da keinen Resolving-Mechanismus gibt. Was tun wir eigentlich? Also bei LiquidFeedback ist der Pfad halt relativ klar. Da kann ich halt versuchen, die Anregung zu geben. Und wenn sie nicht gehört wird, muss ich halt eine eigene Initiative schreiben. Und das sind halt sozusagen klare Regeln. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ich habe die allerletzte Version von Autocracy nicht gesehen. Eine der vorhergehenden Versionen hatte halt eben das Problem, dass wenn sich eben Leute streiten, kann das halt zu einem Problem kommen. Es kann halt auch jemand das Thema sagen, der eine sagt, es soll in Abstimmung gehen, dann am Ende wird es vielleicht wieder zurückgezogen. Geht dann wieder in die Diskussionsphase. Also es ist halt so ein bisschen, ja, da denke ich, da muss man noch ein bisschen was ausarbeiten, damit das schlüssiger ist. Aber ansonsten, was der Talkressi halt tut, ist, dass es eben auch das Delegated Voting konsequent wohl umsetzt.
Was ich ja noch ganz interessant fand, das haben wir jetzt nur so am Rande mitbehandelt, dass ja jetzt eigentlich mit dieser Delegated Voting-Bewegung, weiß nicht, kann man das schon eine Bewegung nennen, auf jeden Fall ist es bei den Piraten sehr stark, aber ich finde es auch selber sehr interessant, dass man überhaupt erst mal über neue Modelle und Abstimmungsmodelle nachdenkt, dass ja auch die Abstimmung als solche da auch nochmal neu zur Diskussion gekommen ist. Wir hatten das ja schon, zwei Systeme, sind jetzt in LiquidFeedback da am Start, also das Approval Voting, was glaube ich bei den Piraten auch so für die eigentlichen Wahlen zum Einsatz kam, auch nur über das Erfahrung, das wir auch beim CCC gemacht haben, seit dem Approval Voting eingeführt wird, dass man einfach deutlich weniger Streit bei so einfachen Wahlen hat, also auch bei geheimen Wahlen vor allem. Das ist ja die große Stärke, nicht wahr? Man hat so einen größeren Pool von Leuten, die jetzt für, was weiß ich, Vorstandswahlen antreten. Und dann hat man immer so dieses Problem, dass dann so ein Spalter da so am Start ist, der alle ganz heiß macht und dann sehen alle als notwendig an, den jetzt zu verhindern. Und tun das, indem sich dann irgendwie noch drei andere Leute aufstellen lassen, die dann schön die Unterstützerstimmen unter sich aufteilen mit dem Ergebnis, das genau das sozusagen das Gegenteil bewirkt hat. Das ist ja etwas, was durch Approval-Voting ganz gut eingefangen wird, in meiner Erfahrung.
Es wird nicht vollständig verhindert, aber es wird gemindert auf jeden Fall. Und wenn man sich anguckt, wie aufwendig Approval-Voting ist, dann ist Approval-Voting ein sehr guter Kompromiss, meiner Meinung nach, bei Wahlen.
Um das durchzuführen, weil man muss ja eigentlich nichts anderes machen als einfach alle Optionen auf dem Zettel zu schreiben und dann kreuzt man halt alle an, die für einen in Frage kommen, und der Reste lässt man weg.
Es kann aber trotzdem im Extremfall nicht ganz verhindert werden, dass halt auch ein ganz unbeliebter Kandidat vielleicht dazu führt, dass ich dann mein Stimmverhalten modifiziere und dann vielleicht kompromissbereiter werde, was mein Ankreuzverhalten angeht, und vielleicht dann lieber einen mehr ankreuze, obwohl vielleicht der Kandidat, der angetreten ist, überhaupt gar keine Chance hatte. Das heißt, es wird halt nicht 100% verhindert, dieses taktische Verhalten, aber es wird halt schon gedämpft.
Was ich gemerkt habe, warum ich das jetzt auch noch mal erwähne, ist, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, also bei den Abstimmungen, die ich so mal umstritten habe, die eben so nach diesem rein, ich kann einem die Stimme geben und dem anderen nicht. Und dann merke ich, wie so meine Stimmen komplett versanden. Was ja auch so bei uns jetzt in Deutschland, was weiß ich, wenn ich jetzt immer ja auch Piratenproblematik habe, ist meine Stimme nicht vergeben, wenn ich die Piraten wähle. Weil die ja nur unter 5 Prozent kommen und dann nimmt meine Stimme sozusagen am demokratischen Prozess gar nicht mehr teil. Das ist ja so eine gängige Angst, die da mit reinkommt. Aber auch im Kleinen, gerade eben wieder dieses Beispiel Vorstandswahl, wo dann die Stimme verloren geht, da merke ich dann halt, dass derjenige, der sich dann an der Wahl beteiligt hat, der sozusagen hier Demokratie-Teilnahme ausgehört hat, ein extremes Frustrationspotenzial aufbaut. Und dass Approval Voting an der Stelle eine ganz andere Einsicht auch in den Verlust macht. Das heißt also, wenn man merkt, dass die eigene Stimme oder die eigene Präferenz nicht durchkam, dass man dann doch nicht so sehr das Gefühl hat, jetzt komplett überfahren worden zu sein. Sondern dass man schon gesehen hat, ah, alles klar, mein Kandidat hat 17 Punkte bekommen. Man summiert das ja einfach alles so auf. Und naja, der threshold lag halt bei 20. Das war halt irgendwie knapp vorbei. Aber ich habe zumindest das Gefühl, dass das Maximum an Unterstützung, was im Raum war, ihm auch zugute kam. Dass das aber nicht gereicht hat. Und dass es jetzt nicht nur so eine taktische Geschichte ist, die das Ganze weggerissen hat.
Ja, also ich nenne es mal grundübel, ist halt die Mehrheitswahl mit einer Abstimmungsmöglichkeit, die halt als Abstimmungs- und Wahlverfahren immer noch verbreitet ist. Und dieses Verfahren hat halt einfach eine Reihe von sehr negativen Eigenschaften. Und dazu zählt halt eben auch, dass ich quasi genötigt werde im Prinzip, meine Stimme, also wenn da jetzt so zwei Kandidaten irgendwie auf der Kippe stehen, dass ich eigentlich für meinen dritten Kandidaten, der irgendwie vielleicht nicht so hohe Chancen habe, sozusagen das System fordert mich geradezu auf, doch einen der beiden Spitzenkandidaten zu wählen. Und im Extremfall führt das dann halt bei Parteien zu einem Zwei-Parteien-System, bei dem irgendwie eine dritte Partei keine Chance hat, sich zu entwickeln. Oder eben im Falle von Antragsentwicklung wird es halt dazu führen, dass Leute sich halt auch nicht trauen, eine Alternative einzustellen, weil die Alternative dann eine Spaltung der Stimmen und damit einen Verlust für die Gesamtidee bedeuten würde. Und mathematisch fasst man das unter, also dieses Stimmensplitting von ähnlichen Alternativen ist halt das sogenannte Independence-of-Clones-Kriterium. Und da ist halt das Abstimmungsverfahren, das LiquidFeedback einsetzt, am Ende die Schulzemethode, die erfüllt eben dieses Kriterium. Das heißt, wenn es ähnliche Vorschläge gibt, dann nehmen sich diese nicht zwingend die Stimmen weg gegenseitig. Und dieses Kriterium, das wurde erst in den 80er Jahren, soweit ich weiß, überhaupt formuliert. Das heißt, das sind alles relativ neue wissenschaftliche Sachen, die in unseren üblich eingesetzten Wahl- und Abstimmungsverfahren kaum einzubringen. Und ich glaube, dass sich da noch ganz viel entwickeln muss. Auch jenseits der Online-Demokratie, auch in Offline-Angelegenheiten muss man tatsächlich diese Sachen diskutieren und auch Verfahren einfach mal anpassen und auf den Stand der Zeit bringen.
Habt ihr euch immer darüber Gedanken gemacht, was man so für Vorschläge machen könnte für die Bundestagswahl?
Also bei der Bundestagswahl würde mir zu spontan einfallen, dass es halt eine Ersatzstimme geben muss eigentlich für den Fall, dass die von mir gewählte Partei eigentlich über die 5%-Hürde kommt.
Dass sozusagen auf jeden Fall eine Stimme quasi mitzählt.
Das fände ich persönlich halt wichtig. Ich würde, muss ich sagen, ich würde auch trotz vielen einer solchen Ersatzstimme trotzdem eine Stimme der Piratenpartei geben, weil ich auch wenn sie nicht über die 5%-Hürde kommt halt sehe, dass es ein politisches Statement ist, was ja auch realpolitische Auswirkungen hat. Aber das sehen halt auch nicht alle so. Und ich denke, dass es halt für das System auf jeden Fall sinnvoll wäre, wenn es halt eben irgendwie eine Möglichkeit einer solchen Ersatzstimme gibt. Im Prinzip ist es ja analog zu der Zweitpräferenz in Liquid Feedback. Nur, dass du halt in Liquid Feedback eben eine beliebig lange Liste machen kannst. Bei so einer Bundestagswahl müsste man halt darauf achten, dass das Verfahren halt auch möglichst einfach ist, damit die Auszählung halt auch nicht so komplex wird.
Aber wie würde sich denn das, ist denn so ein Modell wie so was wie Approval Voting, wäre das nicht auch ein Ansatz?
Man muss erstmal natürlich unterscheiden bei Wahl- und Abstimmungsverfahren. Es gibt Verfahren, sogenannte Single-Winner-Verfahren. Und es gibt halt Verfahren, bei denen es darauf ankommt, dass die gewählten Vertreter ein repräsentatives Bild der Wähler wiedergeben. Das sind zwei ganz unterschiedliche Verfahren. In dem einen Fall ist es nämlich so, also in Single-Winner-Verfahren, da können halt 51 Prozent alles entscheiden. In dem Falle dieser Verfahren, die eben repräsentativ arbeiten, können eben 51 Prozent eben auch nur über 51 Prozent der Plätze entscheiden. Das heißt, Approval Voting passt da eigentlich gar nicht. So wie ich das gerade überblicke, gar nicht. Es gibt halt andere Verfahren, zum Beispiel Single-Transferable Vote, was in Irland eingesetzt wird, wohl aber dort in der eingesetzten Art und Weise. Das konkrete Verfahren ist da wohl auch sehr anfällig für taktisches Wählen. Es gibt da wohl auch neue Entwicklungen, unter anderem auch, glaube ich, von Markus Schulze, der da ähnliche, also die Schulzemethode, die jetzt in LiquidFeedback eingesetzt ist, ist ja ein Single-Winner-Verfahren. Es gibt auch ein Verfahren, was eben eine Verhältniswahl ermöglicht, mit Präferenzen. Und das ist auch relativ neu, ich glaube auch erst sozusagen in diesem Jahrtausend, also 2002 oder so. Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber da wird gerade auch tatsächlich extrem dran geforscht an diesem Thema.
Also sozusagen das heiße Eisen hier, nicht irgendwie alter Scheiß. Ich verweise ja auch immer ganz gerne auf andere CAEs, die sich mit ähnlichen Themen schon mal auseinandergesetzt haben. Ich habe noch gar nichts erwähnt, aber muss ich jetzt mal erwähnen. Ich hatte eine Sendung gemacht, ganz allgemein zu Wahlrecht. Da ging es sozusagen mehr so um die ganzen rechtlichen Probleme, die in Deutschland so vorherrschen. Gerade so diese Sitzverteilungsproblematik, Wagenmandate und dieser ganze Klimbin mit Martin Fenrich von wahlrecht.de. Da kamen wir auch teilweise auf Wahlsysteme zum Sprechen, allerdings nicht so ausführlich wie jetzt. CAE 128. Und ich finde das ehrlich gesagt ganz spannend. Und ich finde auch das sehr angemessen und auch sehr schön, dass gerade so die technisch orientierte Community sich jetzt dieser Thematik annimmt. Nicht nur so, weil es jetzt so verlockend ist, das dann auch gleich in Software zu gießen, sondern weil es natürlich auch einfach sehr interessant ist, überhaupt die Systematiken von Machtverteilung und Machtrepräsentation auch überhaupt erst mal zu verstehen und Systeme zu schaffen, sei es jetzt technische Systeme oder eben auch rein gesellschaftliche Offline-Systeme, wie du so schön sagtest, die eben das Ähnliche machen, um auch einfach für die Eigenorganisation, Piratenpartei ist ja auch nur ein Beispiel, überhaupt erst mal Systeme zu bauen, wo eben die Akzeptanz der demokratischen Kultur innerhalb der Organisation hoch ist, um einfach eine hohe Motivation auch zu erreichen, aber eben auch Systeme zu bauen, die eben ein effizientes Wirtschaften mit der Zeit, mit der wenigen, die man dann doch hat, zu ermöglichen, um auch zu einem kollektiven Ziel anzukommen, selbst wenn keine hohe Streitkultur an der Stelle überhaupt vorhanden ist, sondern es einfach nur darum geht, schnell zu ordnen, Was man denn eigentlich möchte, genau das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall spannend und ich kann auch nur jedem raten, sich damit mal ausführlich zu beschäftigen. Ja, Mensch, haben wir noch irgendwas ganz wichtiges vergessen, Jan?
Nö, ich glaube wir haben alle spannende Fragen der Menschheit bearbeitet.
Super, ja dann sag ich mal vielen Dank für die Ausführung. Ganz tolle, ganz tolle Geschichte war das hier. Super CRE, ich bin ganz glücklich und ich hoffe euch hören geht es genauso hier. Ich freue mich hier auf das Feedback für diese Sendung. Kann ja mal wieder ein bisschen auf die Kanäle hinweisen hier. Blog, Chaosradio, CCCDE, bei uns ist ja immer alles sehr schön zerfranst und durcheinander. Also es gibt das Blog für die Kommentare und es gibt Chaosradio, CCCDE, wo das ganze Archiv der Sendung ist. Ja, vielleicht, wir haben es auch noch nicht aufgefallen, dass seit einiger Zeit haben wir auch BitTorrent-Feeds, wem das was sagt, also wer einen schnellen Bezug der Sendung Interesse hat und nicht unbedingt auf iTunes angewiesen ist, beim Bezug von Podcasts, kann sich auch mal ein Miro installieren und dann den BitTorrent-Feed installieren, dann kommt das ganze auch noch sehr viel schneller an. Ja, und jetzt fällt mir auch nichts mehr ein. Nochmal danke, Jan, und danke fürs Zuhören, und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.